领队就开始强行Q每个人自我介绍，说你叫什么，你从哪来的，你的工作是什么，是相亲团吗，是相亲团。
我甚至是一度就是饭都吃不下去，我要回去找那个小哥，我当时特别后悔，我说我怎么，我怎么不等他通过了，我再走啊。
我说我去，我去，我去，我跟你们一起去。结果去那儿了说，说雅婷，到你了，你进去吧，我在这儿给你看着。
我说啊，我说啊，是这个意思吗。
哈喽，大家好。怎么说来着。
这也是还没想到。
停根太久。
说已经忘了自己的波克林。
哈喽，大家好，这里是还没想好。
我是大壮。
我是雅婷。
我是朗兹。
然后我们今天还有另外一个听众嘉宾，是郝大宇。
OK，那我们今天这期播客是想聊一下雅婷之前去新疆旅游的整条路线。
如果是关注雅婷的朋友们，肯定在过年的前后把这些视频都已经看过了。
那几期视频其实是我看着雅婷的视频，除了她做手术之外的，就是很感动的几期。
不知道就是在座的其他各位有没有这种感觉。
其他两个人有看吗？
我还是觉得那个景卖山那期是我的听我心里的天花板。
好的，好确实是。
那我觉得新疆这几期质量也很高。
那这期我们主要让雅婷带我们重新走一趟这一趟新疆的这个行程。
Hello，好呀，好呀。
那如果到这儿是新听众的话，可以点开shownouts，然后按照我们的时间线从节目正式开始的时候去听。
如果是老听众的话，然后想再跟大家多聊两句。
其实我们已经停更了，快一年了。
一年左右了，然后中间其实收到过很多朋友们的吹耕。
我这边反正是收到过很多朋友们的吹耕。
我不知道雅婷那边。
我昨天发了个微博，就是我们在群里面不是在那呐喊吗，说这次绝不停耕，然后我就把那个节目发了个微博。
在我评论里边，就是两个评论我印象特别是，一个是说，因为你们太久不更新，我已经把小宇宙卸载了。
然后还有一个说，小宇宙大神。
小宇宙还有一个人说，他说，因为你们太久不更新，我已经忘记柏克明叫什么了。
我这边确实也经常在评论和私信里面收到大家的吹耕。
但其实也不是不想更新，就是真的是一直在考虑说，这样节目要跟大家去拿什么样的内容去交流。
但是最近，因为我现在在西藏的拉萨，然后我马上要开始一个差不多一到两周去赶人摩奇的这个转山的行程。
然后我到了西藏之后，可能西藏这个地方就是很容易会让人有更多的感受和想法出来。
所以到这儿，我突然就想到说，我们几个人去过很多地方，而且我们节目之前本身就是在聊我们去过的那些地方看到的人，然后经历的故事。
那我们就继续聊这个就可以啊，这个就是我们的主线内容啊。
对，然后我就想到这儿之后，就立马在我们三个，就是我牙亭还有浪子，没有好大雨啊。
对，我们的这个波克群里面，就跟大家同步了我的这个想法，然后大家都是比较认同的。
所以我们就约了一个最近大家都有时间的时间，其实现在已经是周三晚上十点十七分了。
然后亚庭其实刚下班回到家来跟大家录这期新的节目。
哎，让你们俩也可以介绍一下就是你们现在你们最近这一年的情况或者你们最近在干嘛。
脑子最近在干嘛，我还挺好奇的呀。
我不是之前要去了他泰国吗？
然后回来之后就是其实就是家人家里面有一些就是病痛的折磨在家里面，就是一直在待在家里面也没有出去。
然后最近也在沉浸湿的在减肥。
今天刚上完刚去乐客上完一个B一堂BJ回来。
效果如何？
效果挺好的。
我现在觉得我那个我的整个体能和心肺一直在往上走了，就很棒。
以前打BC或者这些东西都我可能坚持不下来解科，现在完全没问题。
有从那个视频框框里面有感受到那个面积有效味。
对吧。
啊，这就是我的一个简直的效果。
我觉得大家都去减肥吧。
还是在贵阳是吗？
对啊。
从我去了贵阳以他就是狂吃了五天之后，我觉得在贵阳就是没法减肥。
很难。
真的很难减肥。
你卖出这一步，我真的是。
我真的是尊敬。
你在贵阳减肥。
真是贵阳减肥。
他把这个录下来。
这太好吃了。
怎么办呢？
就是很难啊。
太难了。
随便自己搞点什么东西都很好吃。
加油吧，好吧，加油。
加油吧，祝福吧，祝福。
再次尊敬。
尊敬。
是你逼我。
站在那就是个冰。
OK，安婷呢？
我最近就是日常的工作，
但是最近让我非常兴奋，
我一直觉得日子有一个叛逃的是，
我这个月底即将第二次出发去新疆。
就是我自己也觉得挺意外，
挺突然的，
做这个决定也很疯狂。
然后你那天跟我说，
要不再聊聊新疆，
我也觉得这个时间点很好，
那就趁机再回忆一遍，
冬天那一趟第一次新疆，
然后马上就开启我的第二次新疆。
一个特别好的时间点。
一切都非常的合适。
合适一划了。
这样的话也抵消了，
就是因为你们跟雷拉在一起，
在西藏说实话，
就是我每天在刷那个裙，
我每天在看会不会有些新进展，
然后说实话就是新一个是养的，
然后我觉得这次新疆的机会也特别好。
怎么会突然又想去新疆啊？
第二次去新疆是，
首先是还是特别喜欢新疆这个地方，
然后新疆最漂亮的其实就是现在这个月份，
就是5月6月是新疆最漂亮的时候，
然后刚好就是福保又邀请了我，
然后又可以去解锁新疆一个就是很少人去的地方，
叫天堂湖，
其实也邀请了我，
对，也邀请了石阿状，
但是我因为这是西藏的这个行程，
确实赶不过去，
我自己觉得非常遗憾，
非常之可惜，
对对对，
但是我以后一定会去的，
福保也一定也，
我觉得未来肯定也会见到，
是的,
刚好刚刚聊到了福保，
我第一次去新疆旅行也是因为福保，
跟福保认识，
然后也是因为报的福保的女团，
所以一切她都一环扣一环一环扣一环，
这是因为有了第一次去新疆，
我觉得也才有我第二次去新疆的机会，
因为新疆是一个非常大非常大的地方，
就是如果你自己一个人玩，
或者是你不抱团玩的话，
你其实很难玩，
就是它景区跟景区，
地方跟地方之间又隔得特别远，
对,
所以其实我跟余生朗，
之前也规划过好多次想去新疆，
然后都没有去成的一个特别大的原因，
就是地方太大，
太难玩了，
然后租车，
然后如果自己租车的话，
我不太会开车，
然后就只能往四雨开，
然后就压力就会很大，
然后如果抱团的话，
其实费用不便宜，
对,
然后我跟你们一样，
就是因为我其实大学的时候，
就是玩的好的也是新疆的嘛，
所以我知道新疆很美，
然后其实我近两三年，
我都其实一直在网上关注那种，
专门做新疆旅游团的那种，
就是有，
比如说像，
甚至有那种大厂裸辞，
去新疆创业，
我甚至会对这种旅行团，
抱有更多的好感，
因为我觉得他一定在大厂吃了很多苦，
一定很懂什么用户体验，
然后我就会额外关注，
你知道吗，
你也关注了，
对对对，
我也刷到过，
一个叫什么的小斑狼，
对对对，
对吧,
就是他之前也是自己的，
对，是的，
我也关注他了，
所以就是前前后后，
我觉得这两三年，
我大概前前后后，
就认真就是感兴趣且，
而且我还加了小斑狼的微信，
然后就是，
就了解到这种程度，
是真的很感兴趣，
以前大概有三四家吧，
我觉得，
我看起来还比较靠谱的那种，
然后福报这个是，
在2024年1月份的时候，
我也是就是刷，
刷那个抖音，
就是一个非常漂亮的女生，
然后画着非常精致的妆容，
然后口才非常的好，
然后他大概就是，
对着镜头，
就是调理非常清楚，
为什么他的新疆团，
七天不玩，
就是玩一个精致的小环线，
然后以及他的团，
为什么要一万多，
一下就把我说服了，
我立刻关注，
然后加了他们客服的微信，
然后就开始了解，
这还是2024年的时候，
1月份的时候，
我就说，
如果我去新疆，
到时候一定就是，
就是看一看是否报他们的团，
这是2024年的1月份，
然后突然这个女生，
就长时间不更新，
就福报这个女生，
就他那一条视频给我，
他就是一个事业女强人，
然后再到2024年9月份，
苏报他突然更新，
他说他得了子宫内膜癌，
我靠,
就是那个给我的冲击，
就是怎么会这样，
然后他就是对着镜头，
他在杭州接受治疗，
然后他身上插着那个药管，
然后他头发也掉光了，
再推给我的时候，
他就已经这样了，
然后再到，
我自己在2024年，
就是10月国庆的时候，
就也是9月底，
做了一个很大的手术，
就大家可能不要了解，
就我去做了一个苏兄手术，
就也是在手术室里边躺了，
六七个小时，
然后我觉得某种程度上，
我跟福报，
就是是，
感觉明明中，
就有一些，
可能有一些类似的体验吧，
就那种感觉，
然后我在手术恢复期间，
发视频的时候，
福报同时，
除了做旅游团，
他还做那个冷吃，
就是他也是折腾，
从大学，
也不好好学习，
然后就开始折腾，
就是搞小作坊，
卖冷吃，
然后卖到现在，
冷吃兔那些，
对，就是鲁味，
做的鲁味，
有蒋中堡，
排骨,
然后现在，
他爸爸妈妈，
再给他做，
然后我就在网上，
买了他的，
在他的那个微店，
买了一箱冷吃，
我就在那儿拆，
因为我平时也会录自己的vlog，
然后天天干嘛呀，
我就拆那个冷吃，
福报的闺蜜一直在关注我，
他一看，
他就看到我拆到
福报的那个冷吃了，
然后他就告诉了福报，
福报就知道
我在他那儿买冷吃了，
同时当天的视频里边，
我也说，
我说,
福报是个什么样的人，
我为什么要关注福报，
我说,
希望我下次去新疆的时候，
福报的身体能够康复，
当然那个时候，
我对新疆旅游，
我还觉得是很远之后的事情，
都是我老代在想，
在幻想，在幻想的那种，
好，然后，
时间就来到了，
2024年的十一，
十一月份，
还是十二月份，
因为那次视频的互动，
福报跟我留言说，
祝我早日康复，
然后他说，
他也在慢慢恢复身体，
他就，我俩就互观了，
因为我们这种就是，
本着就是福报，
八十万多万粉丝，
是那种大网红，
关系到互观为止，就OK了，
就是不敢多打扰，
就是完全就没有哈拉呀，怎么怎么样，
然后我又怕我，
刻意的接近他，
显得是他硬要给我折扣，
或是怎么怎么样，
就只是，
就只是停留在抖音互观，
好，然后再到2024年的，
大概是十二月份，
福报就说，
我的一离团，
那条线路开始了，
说我敢不敢兴趣，
说我有没有兴趣来玩，
但是十二月份，
正是我最忙的时候，
就是我在全国各地出差，
然后我就，
我就挽聚了，
我就说，福报，
就是谢谢你的，
就是好心邀请，
我说我，
年底实在是太忙了，
我说，我说那个有机会，
我再去那个新疆，
就也就停留在这儿，
然后到相当于，
到2024年的十二月份，
我跟福报，
就正式加上了微信，
然后就因为这个契机，
好，然后，
福报属于那种，
朋友圈儿更新的，
表达越比较旺盛的人，
他更新的比较频繁，
然后这个期间，
他一直在杭州进行治疗，
我,我,
他身体确实比较虚弱，
所以我平时完全就没有跟他，
完全都没有跟他聊天哦，
因为我不敢打扰他，
我觉得他身体很虚弱，
然后再到，
快要过年回家了，
福报发了一条朋友圈儿，
他说，安乐太团，
只有一个位置了，
就反正就是名额比较少，
我一想，
我说，我不是不想待在家吗，
我要不就趁机，
他发的那个朋友圈儿，
就觉得这种人特别心动，
就是妈，
只有谨慎一个席位了，
赶紧再抢啊，
你现在不带动了，
那我不就冲一把子吧，
就是在家，
就出衣，出衣就走，
我从来没有出衣就走过，
过完年就走，
他们那个行程，
就是那个新年团，
过完年就走，
因为新疆人不过新年，
你说,
哎，你当时，
这个是你当时也邀请我，
那个什么，
对对对，
你问我要不要去，
有在说，
不是怎么就剩一个席位了，
还邀请人呢，
不是,
在这,
在此之前，
在这之前，
然后其实我们俩就有商量说，
过年选一个地方，
但是不一定是新疆，
然后去玩，
对对对，
不一定是新疆，
然后就说，
可以去，
然后,
这两天给到我，
他的时间之后，
我说不行，
我要过年了，
对，他回来过年，
我说我，
一天都不想在家待着，
然后,
因为在这之前，
就是前年，
再往前到，
我就一个人吃了墨盒嘛，
前天也是我妈，
又被诈骗了七八万，
哈,
就一个人去墨盒，
玩特别不开心，
好，然后再问我，
这张片的事，
我们有机会再跟大家分享吧，
我觉得，
是一个，
公益下的内容，
真的真的，
好,
如果,
如果大家，
如果大家想听的话，
可以在那个，
评论系里面，
告诉我们，
那个诈骗，
妈妈被诈骗了一声，
哈哈哈，
半声嘛，
半声，半声，
现在已经虚微觉醒，
关系也缓和了很多，
嗯,
大家不要觉得，
我们在这儿笑，
是那个，
觉得,
不礼貌，
对，不礼貌这件事，
真的不是，
就是因为我们，
可能,
确实,
都了解一些，
这些里面的，
故事,
所以,
好，说回来，
两天也不会生气，
嗯,好,
然后就想着，
前年去墨盒，
自己也不是很开心，
不想待在家，
然后今年就说，
那就,
那就充一吧，
初一就，
就跟着，
跟团吧，
好,
然后我就去找，
那个福保了，
就抱了那个阿拉泰的团，
然后呢，
其实福保当时，
就是他们的那个，
不是很好，
哦,
就是阿拉泰团，
就是,
除了,
新年过后，
后边就没有人陆续在，
抱了,
大概是这种情况，
然后福保就说，
嗯,
说那个，
成本也挺高的，
然后就说，
反正就是，
我就按那个，
原价格，
给他付款了，
然后福保说，
如果你在这个时候，
我还没有出发的时候，
福保就说了，
他说,
你如果有兴趣的话，
时间还够的话，
你阿拉泰玩玩，
我邀请你，
再来一里玩几天，
就那时，
这样,
就是留了一个话口，
但是我当时就说，
我先把阿拉泰玩完再说，
嗯,
因为我心里也是没笔的，
就大概，
就这样，
就,
就抱上了这个团，
对,
然后就开始了，
就张诺，
就回家，
稍微提前，
几天回家，
过了年，
过完年初一，
我妈就非常的，
在一个冷清的机场，
把我送上了，
飞往新疆的飞机，
我现在觉得，
好绝绝啊，
我妈,
我妈好可怜啊，
好好好，
这就是，
这就是跟，
呃,
一些为什么，
就是,
抱上福保团的一些，
交代吧，
那我们其实，
主要想先，
跟大家聊一下，
那个,
关于这个团是怎么玩的，
然后,
以及就是，
大家如果听这个节目的话，
怎么去借鉴，
这个,
形成,
对,
我觉得是，
首先我们刚刚也说了，
新疆,
它其实，
真的是只有抱团玩，
你自家玩会很累，
然后,
福保的这个，
很多,
因为新疆牛团，
这种五花八门嘛，
啊,
这里也不是，
给福保达什么广告，
也确实是我，
就是亲身经历下来，
嗯,
福保这个团是，
他们真的是，
一次又一次的，
去采现，
然后去体验，
去亲自吃那儿的饭，
呃,
以及去亲自住那儿的民宿，
采完的这个县，
觉得是相对合理的，
包括每一家餐厅，
都是他们，
他自己带着人去，
一家一家的市吃，
然后选出来的，
呃,
不是那种，
就是我要，
我要办个，
我要办个那个，
旅游团了，
我就,
签个供应商，
找个外包，
然后签这家，
签那家，
都不是，
然后甚至，
福保身体好的时候，
他是亲自带团的，
然后他可能现在，
后来他身体就是，
嗯,
不太好了，
而且呢，
呃，也是非常值得，
大家参考的，
他是一个很科学，
又不是很累人，
又能够尽量的，
把阿勒泰的，
经典的景区，
看到的一个路线，
嗯,
那我就，
正式开始，
阿勒泰之旅了，
这钱摇摇了，
二十两个钟，
不过没关系，
捡吧,
我们就是，
一党这样的节目，
现在还，
我们就是这样一党，
瞎聊的节目，
呃,
行程的第一天，
就是抵达，
那个阿勒泰市，
就下午五点之前，
这个团的人，
一起在阿勒泰下午，
就是集合，
其实因为我，
没有去过新疆朗，
其实也没去过，
你去过吗？
你去过新疆朗？
他去的哪儿？
你去的哪儿？
对,
我去了雾木齐，
然后去了，
北屯,
啊,
我,
没听说过，
是天池，然后，
呃,
没听说过，
没有,
就是,
不尊重，
那个北屯，
这个地方的意思，
只是客观的表达一下，
我确实没有听过，
这个,
地方的，
那个,
太小声了，老师，
对,
那个意思，
没有任何的奇迹，
因为我平时说话，
就很喜欢，
就是这种，
这种,
所以大家，
不要觉得我，
说话,
就带有很多，
攻击性，
谢谢大家，
我是一个，
嗯,
喜欢淋雨的，
然后,
那,
刚才来了一个新的，
课作听众，
然后,
是,
蒋老师，
你去过新疆吗？
没有,
OK,
哈哈哈，
蒋老师，
愿意当这个，
当这个，
呃,
听众吗？
他听不见，
因为我们带着耳机，
啊,
我有个问题，
我现在，
我现在有个问题啊，
嗯,
就是,
因为之前那部剧也很火麻阿勒赛，
嗯,
但是我，
对对对对，
其实,
没有太弄明白，
没有查地图啊，
就是,
阿勒泰氏，
和阿勒泰，
他们的关系是什么？
以及,
我刚刚想问的这个问题，
就是,
阿勒泰在新疆的一个，
什么地方，
然后他大概是，
是什么情况之类的，
因为,
我确实没有这部分的，
人之,
请雅婷老师，
给我们介绍一下吧，
那他,
那我也没有，
因为我就是，
哈哈哈，
抱团了，
我就是，
不带老子，
就是玩，
但是我只知道一点，
就是,
有一个区叫阿勒泰，
然后这个阿勒泰区有，
这个是那个是，
其中有一个是，
叫阿勒泰氏，
然后还有就是，
呃,
首先就是，
我没有看，
阿勒泰那个电视剧，
我知道评分很高，
评价也很高，
哦,
你当时好像跟我说过，
说你,
年底要去，
然后所以你就，
没看是吗？
不是没看，
是我,
是我一直都不太感兴趣，
因为我不太喜欢，
于是,
这一款，
对,
这段咔掉，
所以我对那个剧，
我知道那个剧，
评价很高，
然后,
评分也很高，
但是我一直，
但是我一直不感兴趣，
你知道吧，
所以,
但是我出发之前，
一直在看，
你觉得呢，
都牧场，
就是写的那个阿勒泰，
对对对，
还是,
出发之前，
就是紧急，
补充一些，
文学素养，
哈哈哈，
其实我，
也推荐大家，
如果去一个新的地方，
旅行的话，
可以带上，
一本讲，
这个地方的书，
真的会，
超级,
拉开你不同的认知，
就是,
你一部分在现实，
你身体，
在,
在这个地方，
然后你看到了，
接触了这些，
然后你同时还会回想，
看，你书里边，
看到那些，
然后坐着，
讲到那些东西，
然后,
一切就重合了，
那个感觉是，
非常非常，
对，我，我这个，
你刚刚描述那个感觉，
非常同意，
超级美妙，
嗯,
你描了四十分钟，
还没,
还没开始说，
把我们，
就是这样一个节目，
真的,
然后那个，
大家,
大家冲着那个，
到时候我们那个，
标题进来听，
结果前面，
听了一个半个小时，
废话,
我们现在，
这档节目的定位，
是至今跟宇宙结婚，
如果大家没有，
如果大家，
听过这样节目的话，
就明白我在说，
什么意思，
如果没有听过的话，
就去听一下，
对,
欢迎大家去关注，
跟宇宙结婚，
我先,
我先大概说一下，
精华的，
就是精华的说一下，
这几天的行程吧，
阿拉泰一共是玩了七天，
然后第一天是抵达，
阿拉泰市，
然后跟团一起聚餐，
大家互相认识一下，
然后第二天是，
逛阿拉泰市，
几乎就在，
阿拉泰市区活动，
比如说逛，
逛集市呀，
然后吃一些特色的餐厅呀，
起码呀，
然后去江军山之类的，
然后第三天，
我们就离开了阿拉泰，
然后去了河目这个地方，
然后经过了一条，
非常著名的公路，
然后中途会打卡，
然后晚上呀，
入住民宿，
勾火网，
会等等，
这是第三天的行程，
然后第四天的行程是，
去那个，
全亚洲最大的华学厂，
叫吉克普林华学厂，
主要的行程就是在这儿，
华学,
玩一天，
因为那个学厂超级大，
就是反正，
也是在中国的学厂，
里面是比较出名的吧，
然后晚上就在那个村落里边，
看那个，
懒吊时刻，
就也是非常著名的一个景点，
然后第五天，
就是从河目村离开，
然后出发，
去美丽峰，
然后中途会经过，
三湾,
也是非常著名的一个景点，
没有去过新疆的，
可能听，
听到这些景点，
会比较陌生，
但是呢，
去过的，
听到这些景点，
脑海里一定浮现的是那种，
非常震撼的美景，
然后第六天，
第六天，
主要的行程就是，
打卡神仙湾，
然后开车去百哈帕村，
然后也是一路，
新上美景，新上美景，
第七天，
就是回阿勒泰市区，
然后又跟这个团，
相处了七天的团的成员，
然后一起吃饭，
然后晚上入住酒店，
最后呢，
第八天，
就,
大家各自飞走了，
嗯,
这样整理听起来，
其实我觉得，
好像,
一般,
很多时间都是在路上的，
对,
而且就是，
嗯，滑雪，
OK，我自己也能去滑，
然后,
嗯,
打卡,
然后,
好像,
也不是一个有，
多有门槛的，
嗯,
事儿,
然后或者是，
去骑马，
然后,
是不是，
或者别的，
都能自己去安排，
对,
我觉得，
就是,
其实我刚刚那些公寓，
其实,
嗯,
就是,
和从小红书上搜，
我念出来的，
你们可能感受是一样的，
就是它没有什么特别的，
但是我觉得，
这趟旅程就是，
有一些美景，
说我无法用语言形容出来的，
然后,
而且你玩到最后，
我根本都不觉得，
我觉得，
坐车世界好容易的事情啊，
就是这趟旅程，
我觉得给我感触和，
嗯,
印象还有，
还有那种思考，
更多的是人，
嗯,
我们就从第一天开始讲呗，
但是其实，
我刚刚听你说，
第一天那个，
行程安排的时候，
是,
呃,
接机集合，
欢迎晚会，
如果是我的话，
我其实，
对这种，
我会觉得有点，
尴尬,
呃,
我,
时机情况呢？
就是我就是很尴尬，
我第一天，
极其的不适应，
而且你知道，
那个小的那个餐厅，
就是,
是好吃的，
但是因为，
领队加上，
跟团的人，
一起得有，
小二十人了吧，
巨大,
那个，那个，
包,包,
包间巨大，
然后,
甚至那个桌子大到，
桌子中间，
有一座假山，
这,
我,
我进去，
我进去头都大了，
我就,
我当时，
你知道，
老子你有一个念头，
我说,
我要,
我要不出去自己逛吧，
就是,
但是,
领队极其热情，
就硬着头皮，
每个人都坐下了，
然后,
就坐下了，
就开始吃饭，
我就,
我就很累想，
然后,
我也,
我也压根就不想，
认识这个团，
你点儿其他的人，
然后,
后来这个，
是有改观的吗，
还是一直跟大家，
我,
玩到最后，
直接跟同车的那个，
驴肉火车，
夫妻打成一片，
然后,
回来后来，
又去了一道，
保定,
谁懂,
然后,
还从,
还让,
保定的，
驴肉火车，夫妻，
从保定，
给我们，
到,
寄了一箱，
驴肉火车，
到海南，
然后,
甚至让，
甚至让保定文艺，
都挺温，
天呐,
做出了，
一大的，
贡献,
然后,
河北文旅，
应该请你去带人，
真的,
周末,
到河北，
好,
又讲完，
完之后呢，
就是一座假事儿，
就,
好,
但是我想象不错，
你知道，
就是,
就是我想象不到一个人，
就是一个，
就是所有人都不认识，
你一个人，
和二十个陌生人，
在一起吃饭，
那个场景，
哇,
对,
真的好地狱，
我觉得我，
真的挺地狱的，
我觉得我生活中，
其实不是一个那种，
一直拿得特别满的，
尤其是在，
这么多人陌生人潮，
而且就是我们这种，
也不是我们这种，
就我这种，
就是经常在，
就是在北京上班呀，
真的,
其实命的要死，
就是,
就是觉得，
哎呀,
这个人，
也就那样，
把桌子上这个人，
哎呀,
什么意思呀，
就是这个也瞧不上，
他也一般，
他也,
他也那样，
哎呀,
都看不上，
都是装祸，
漏祸,
哎,
都不知道我，
我那个抖音有，
有七万粉丝，
哈哈哈，
然后你知道，
有一个人，
特别夸张团，
那边有一个人，
就有个，
瘦瘦的广东的，
年轻的小伙子，
他拿了个大浆，
然后因为那个桌子，
巨大,
我记得是，
转的,
就那个转盘，
都有两层，
还是什么之类的，
每上一个菜，
他就拿起他的大浆，
从桌子上站起来，
跟着那个，
跟着那个菜拍，
就是感觉，
就是特专业，
就跟着那个菜拍，
是个美食博主吗？
不知道，
我当时就是，
金鲁片博主，
我当时就是翻白衣，
我说，哎呦，
不会是个大博主吧，
就那些这种，
然后后来知道，
就是他只是自己拍，
爱发朋友圈，
好，然后，
就是,
而且吃完，
再死,
再死没有，
不尊重，
任何,
喜欢用大浆，
然后拍，
然后爱发朋友圈的，
所有的朋友，
就是,
我们在这儿，
只是,
一个朋友之间，
互相那个，
然后邀请你，
坐在我们的沙发上，
然后,
来跟我们一块，
聊聊天，吐吐藏，
大概是这么一个氛围，
我们尊重，
每个人的艺术追求，
对的，对的，
如果你觉得，
让你不试的话，
那,
抱歉,
而且,
我现在是一个，
我以现在一个状态，
回忆,
我当时的心态，
我是一个，
就是,
很不合适的一个，
对别人一个，
揣测,
而并不是，
我现在是这样想的，
然后,
经过七天的旅程，
我整个心灵，
和我整个人格，
都得到了，
非常大的喜敌，
这么夸张吧，
而且就是，
这次有点，
挺夸张了吧，
一会儿不会讲哭了吧，
快要吃完的时候，
领队就开始强行，
Q每个人自我介绍，
说你叫什么，
你从哪来的，
你的工作是什么，
然后我当时，
是相亲团吗，
我当时，
我当时到我了之后，
当时到我了之后，
就说,
我叫雅婷，
大家可以不用理我，
我是一个哀人，
我说,
嗯，好好好，
就三句话，
我就结束了，
然后来就开始玩游戏，
玩游戏，
我也非常不在状态，
然后第一天，
就这么抓麻的，
结束了，
跟团见似的，
我其实从我的角度，
我会觉得说，
我花钱，
我花了一万，
我花一万多块钱，
然后我来这儿，
不是跟你们来玩这个的，
不是来跟你自我介绍的，
你别给我整那些，
你就赶紧带我去玩，
就行了，
我当时特别渴望，
我身边有个熟人，
就是你记不记得，
有一次我们去爬山，
然后爬山的时候，
那个领队，
然后也在那儿拿个话筒，
让车上的人自我介绍，
妈呀,
然后当时，
因为石大壮是跟我一起的，
然后因为石大壮在我旁边，
他很易啊，
对,
当时爬山是因为石大壮在我旁边，
然后石大壮还拿着人家的话筒，
在那儿说，
大家好，
我叫石大壮，
然后没有了，
谢谢,
然后就把话筒递走了，
在那个大巴车上，
然后如果我当时，
我当时特别渴望，
我身边有个熟人，
我极其难受那个场合，
然后我就一直想着，
什么时候回去，
我本来一开始，
是不打算检视频道，
因为前一天，
我去乌鲁木齐，
见了一趟打热，
然后你知道，
就是我闲着没事，
我躲进厕所，
去把前一天的那个配音给配了，
打热视也挺大学的朋友，
对，大学玩的很好的朋友，
然后,
我就在那儿坐着开始，
坐着开始检视频了，
因为我觉得反正闲着没事，
就是第一天是一种体验，
你知道吗，
然后就入住了，
入住了，
因为我是一个人嘛，
但是其实，
如果我一个人去承担房费的话，
就会非常贵，
如果这样算的话，
所以呢，
像这种有一个人拖单的时候，
我就安排了我跟这个团，
你别的摄影师，
妹妹一起住，
然后他叫雪娇，
然后第一天呢，
雪娇是一个，
可可爱爱的重庆人，
因为我的家是在恩师，
恩师你重庆特别近，
我俩甚至可以用方言交流，
所以第一天晚上，
就简单的和雪娇聊聊天，
然后就睡着了，
然后这就到了第二天，
第二天早上我们就起来去逛，
阿勒泰市去的一个济市，
阿勒泰小小的，
我觉得他都算不上一个市，
就跟县城一样，
然后我当时还在想，
怎么没有网上吹的那么美呀，
其实你那个视频里面，
拍到的有一个市场，
我是在我的阿勒泰这部剧里边，
应该看过的，
就是同一个市场，
然后,
我好像，
好像评论区里面，
我不知道有没有人说，
那个就是，
他奶奶失踪的那个市场，
对,
我当时看到你视频的时候，
但我,
看你没介绍，
然后我就，
我就心想，
啊，他还没看我的，
但是这部剧呀，
OK,
就去了那个济市，
但是,
从,
我觉得从逛济市，
我就,
我觉得我那个旅游的心情，
就回来了，
就是我，
那个济市非常的，
local,
而且那个早上，
我不是，
我觉得新疆的太阳，
会更亮一些，
就早上，
那是一个透顶的，
透光的，
中间是一个圆柱形的，
太阳能直接，
设到那个济市，
然后济市里面就挂满了，
那种,
羊毛呀，
衣服什么的，
对，衣服，
然后那个光影，
就打在了那个，
那个羊毛上，
反正特别好看，
然后感觉大家就是，
穿的特别厚，
就穿的真的，
就跟电视剧里面的人一样，
然后新疆本地人，
就每个人鼻子都超级挺吧，
就你在内地，
就是很难看到，
这么挺的鼻子，
然后,
每个人就是，
谈谈话的鼻子挺挺的，
嗯,
嗯，差不多吧，
然后,
然后每个人就是，
就觉得，
每个本地人都像，
电视剧里面那种人在我旁边，
就是,
我这几天在拉萨也经常有这种感觉，
就是觉得，
看谁,
觉得,
他可以去拍电影，
他可以去拍杂志，
然后他可以出道，
然后今天去那吃饭，
还有两个小哥，
然后叫，
什么,
拿布,
然后另外一个叫，
拉,
忘了,
拉拉吧，
他也叫拉，
唱歌特别好听，
就觉得，
怎么,
就是感觉到了一个意识节，
嗯,
有点，有点这种感觉，
所以那个集视，
我逛,
我突然就是，
心情就特别愉悦，
因为我觉得，
我在旅游，
我也不用在乎，
就是这个团里边，
其他人，
就是到底感受怎么样，
然后我就一个人在，
在里边逛，
对,
就是一些本地的特产，
就是小小的，
然后那个光影特别好看，
然后我心情就特别好，
我们就在那个集视里边逛完，
逛了,
逛了一会儿之后，
就开始，
出发,
就是离开阿拉泰，
去河目，
其实我觉得，
这里面还有一个点是，
其实我们都是会对这种，
比如说，
去个当地的集视，
去,
这种,
地方特别感兴趣的人，
所以就是，尤其会，
对,
会对这个就是，
会更,
有那种感觉，
会一下把你拉到，
哦,
我已经开始，
一趟,
好新鲜啊，
这个也要看，
对对对，
是是,
那你买什么东西了吗？
没有,
没有，没有嘛，
就是我，
我更,
我特别，
就我去每个地方，
包括出差，
如果我有时间的话，
我就会去逛本地的菜市场，
但是我也不额外买什么，
就是很享受那个逛的感觉，
嗯,
然后刚刚，
刚刚有点口误，
就是,
没有这么快离开阿拉泰市，
刚刚讲匹差了，
就我们逛完集视之后，
就被带到去吃新疆的，
特色的，
早餐,
那是我第一次吃，
马肉,
我的妈呀，
马肠,
有我脸盘子那么大吧，
就因为我们，
平时吃的那个香肠，
就是,
它撑死，
就是一根纸头，
或者两根纸头那么粗，
然后感觉那个马肠，
就快要，
有我全都那么粗了，
然后那个横切面，
一切下来，
我真的觉得有我，
有我手掌，
大那个马肠，
我,
吓死了，
我说,
我说新疆都是plus吧，
就是这种感觉，
然后就那个，
就吃的小心翼翼的，
但是就是，
没有觉得，
说有经为天人的好吃，
就是觉得很有特色，
然后尝了一下那个陀来，
然后说，
陀来特别珍贵，
然后,
也特别有营养，
我就想尝一下，
喝了一口，
就过吐了，
特别大的发酵的味道，
我,
形容不出来，
然后就，
就特别，
不会是坏了吧？
真的有点，
有点soul,
有点坏，
没有不尊重陀来的意思，
陀来是，
没有不尊重的意思，
一定是一个好东西，
一定是，
只是我喝不过，
我家现在还有拖奶饼干的，
但是这顿早餐，
印象非常深的是，
新疆的酸奶，
它可以蘸各种果酱，
然后你可以包各种各样的，
就是那种，
监裹,
你就可以裹着，
哇,
那个酸奶好甜，
好甜啊，
就是,
如果不加糖版的，
那个酸奶也非常的浓郁，
是非常好吃，
我觉得可能跟新疆这边，
地域有关吧，
它的酸奶格外，
就是,
味道特别的不错，
新西藏这边也有酸奶，
这人太酸了，
就是我们，
第一天，
还是第二天，
就是去吃饭的时候，
就点了一个那个酸奶，
因为来之前，
就知道，
就是这边也是牧区嘛，
会有奶什么的，
就很想尝尝酸奶，
因为我在，
北京什么的，
就很喜欢，
吃紫光源的那个酸奶，
紫光源的那个酸奶是，
对对对，
就是,
很好吃，
然后,
所以我对酸奶这种东西，
很,
就是,
尊敬很崇拜，
觉得就是，
很好东西，
我很喜欢的，
这种,
预设在里边，
结果,
就酸到，
被你换酸水，
真的太，
就是,
我觉得，
我不知道，
可能跟，
新疆酸奶，
会放蜂蜜，
各种,
蜂蜜果酱，
我这样，
对,
哇,
就是觉得，
这边没有，
可能是会跟不同地方的人，
的饮食习惯，
和,
身体,
或者是，
什么有关吧，
不知道，
和地理条件，
如果有，
知道的，
西藏的朋友，
可以,
给我们普及一下，
那个早餐，
我就记得，
酸奶很好吃，
我们,
我们吃完，
我们吃完就去骑马，
骑马主要就是，
呃,
体验那个，
就是,
当地人，
就会签着一匹马，
然后你就在马上，
去感受，
然后把你签进，
然后走进那种，
地表,
然后你就去，
从一个，
正常的那种，
公路,
然后一直往你走，
往你走，
真的觉得，
就是周围是个森林，
骑马我印象，
嗯,
我没有觉得，
骑马,
就是,
让我,
体验到了那种，
因为我在这之前，
我对骑马的，
那种印象，
完全乃至于，
环珠格格，
我就觉得，
人,
人骑马，
就是要那种，
那种,
那个歌是怎么唱的，
就是,
哼哼哼，
像傻傻傻，
对,
小马奔腾，
攻向人士，
认识法华，
这是我对骑马的印象，
我觉得骑马要这样，
哎，所以，
所以你们不是，
就是,
就是那样骑起来的，
就是全程是，
被别人牵着走，
对,
全程被别人牵着，
你就坐着，
那叫什么骑马呀，
贼马,
特别慢，
就是在那儿慢悠悠的，
就在那儿走，
嗯,
然后,
所以我对骑马，
骑马,
但是走进那个森林里边之后，
我,
我当时，
就是让我觉得，
就是新疆很美的一个感受是，
呃,
骑马到了一个地方，
然后大家就打开拍照嘛，
我就,
我就觉得，
穿那么多，
坐在马上，
就是那样，
挖着,
就是能拍出好看的照片吗，
我就,
我就不想拍照，
然后,
啊,
别冷,
然后,
就有一条河，
在流动，
河两边就是那种，
像,
像那个，
泡沫一样的，
那么高的，
就是雪，
就是呃，
漂漂的那种，
就漂漂的，
然后,
河都没有结冰，
就一直，
就是,
留下来，
然后,
两边都是树，
然后那个树之上，
也就挂满了雪，
就那个雪，
它看起来漂 Bubu favors 吧泡します吧【塞尔】
也是漂 Jacarberia 那% niemand 用亦子凝 (*hs).。
就是,
是软的嘛，
他就他就他就散掉了那种。
那这一点真的特别不一样。
如果大家去东北
吉林什么的这种地方。
看到特别厚的雪
大千万不要就是趴上去。
都是石的特别硬
那那应该我觉得我理解。
应该是那个没有在河边吧？
他可能是因为在跟在河边有关系吧？
而且我让我挺震撼的是。
这么低的温度
那个河流还在流动。
就是那个流动的那个湖。
还是河水
然后旁边又是那么厚的雪。
就是然后
呃
然后那个南天白云。
然后又有很很大的太阳。
就是让我觉得很新奇。
对
我觉得印象深的是这个。
然后在那玩了一会儿就。
开始骑又继续骑马。
又往那边走
在这比较有意思的点是。
我跟那个骑马
就是得有人牵着嘛？
我就跟他聊天
然后他的汉语非常不好。
就那个那个马夫
就在那有一句每一句的。
就是跟大弥域一样。
唯一就是在那
就真的两个外星人在讲话。
唯一一个比较有用的信息就是。
我做的那匹马叫Altima。
Altima
名字叫Altima。
我就记住了这个
然后其他的就是
就完全没有聊出来什么有用的信息。
因为我在外边玩
就是还挺爱跟人聊天的。
我也是
我想问一下
就是你们就是
平常出去和这种陌生人。
比如说就跟这个马夫。
你们都聊什么呀？
就比如说问他马叫什么名字啊？
然后问他那个每天工作多久呀？
然后说那个
你家有几匹马呀什么之类的。
我今天
我今天打车的时候。
还跟当地的西藏司机聊天。
他就他的普通话也不是很好。
但是我就坚持一直在跟他。
对对
就是在跟他说说那个说。
我甚至跟他讲了说我刚才去干嘛？
然后就是刚才那个人就是。
怎么怎么怎么样
然后他还在那劝我说。
哎呀有些人就是怎么怎么样。
我大概听出来是这种意思啊？
然后说他就是应该跟你道歉什么？
但是口音巨重
然后就是半听半猜。
然后聊了一路
啊你知道吗？
说起这个就是我印象最深的。
跟这种司机聊条是。
有一次我下飞机回去。
就是从手机场回到住的地方。
然后那个司机是内蒙的。
然后他出生的那一年。
正好是赶上那个
他出生的那个年代。
正好赶上就是不能生。
不能生二台
就是赶上计划生育。
对然后他们家就是生下他。
生下他之后就把他。
扔在了就是内蒙给他的那个。
脑反正老人还是一个什么亲戚养着。
直到他成年之后
他才他的爸爸妈妈才告诉他。
我是你的亲爸亲吗？
我倒是超级震撼
然后我就说那你现在恨他们吗？
然后那个那个司机年纪也很大了。
就是他自己也四五十岁了。
就他非常就是
仿佛就是看透了世间万物一样。
他说
哎怎么着也是
我自己的亲生父亲了。
就是好残忍啊？
因为他们那个时候为了规避那个罚款。
所以就不能就是一直待在身边。
好像落户也没有落在那儿。
就那样子
我就觉得
就是为了不加罚款吗？
对对对
这是我印象最深的一次。
跟司机的聊天
嗯我也是我也是一个二。
二胎
呃
我我就是第二胎本胎。
但是你们就是交了罚款我们家。
嗯我能再聊
交三万呢？
然后就起码结束之后。
我们就回酒店休息了。
回酒店休息了之后。
下午的行程就是去阿勒泰一个将军山。
啊然后去那行程里边是安排看日落。
将军山是应该也是一个。
非常全国比较著名的滑雪点。
就是因为我刚刚前面不是说了。
我觉得阿勒泰是小小的。
就是我没有觉得阿勒泰是很繁华。
然后他的房屋也矮矮的。
休息了一会就去将军山。
我的妈呀？
到了将军山下
你你真的感受到那个滑雪文化的冲击。
就挨着挨着全部是滑雪店。
然后所有人都穿着。
一看就穿着超级高端的。
就是滑雪装备
Burton Salomon。
对 这是牌子过年色吗？
而且所有的
基本上这些大滑雪厂。
就是它的所有的配套。
它的所有的开发都是国内。
非常顶尖的这种地产商做的。
所以它的配套非常完善。
基本上
但我将军山我确实不太知道。
就是我之前去过的一些学厂就是。
滑雪小镇
就是你住的那些酒店啊？
公寓啊甚至别墅配套的。
然后就是你在小镇上吃饭。
然后什么肯德基什么这个星巴克。
什么这些都别说了。
反正就各种精品店。
它本身也是很割裂的。
其实对
我其实是感觉要割裂的。
你知道吗？
就是一下感觉就繁华起来了。
然后就是每家店就是。
这个也是牌子
或那个也是牌子
然后每个人都是装备特别豪华。
就是感觉突然一下。
又来了另外一个是。
然后这是我对将军山的第一个印象。
我们下完车之后
我抬头一看
就是那种
哇
因为我之前
见到过的那个滑雪。
就是我们
在家里边
村里边那个
一个山坡
然后就是滑下来
然后还是很震撼
因为感觉忘到了好远。
才忘到那个山顶
然后我一下车往上一看。
就有
就上面就有人在做滑翔伞。
我当时就对那个印象特别深。
对
我就看到那个滑翔伞了。
我一看
刚好那个时候
我们下车的时候
就刚好太阳在落
然后我当时老自己想。
我说哇
如果是飘上去再看日落。
得没死了吧？
当时就是这么想的。
然后当时
当时就问了一下
知道是滑翔伞
不在这个行程里边。
我们就继续坐
载车就往上了
就为了去追那个日落。
就运气很不好
追上去日落
就被雾云挡住了
就是勉强有一点点那个余光。
对
雪骄又继续给客人拍照。
那个时候我脑子
雪骄给客人拍照
是在这个所有里边。
就是一直在贯穿的一个点。
说在哪
在码的时候
雪骄在给客人拍照。
我去旁边的河那儿站着。
然后大家往山上走。
雪骄给客人拍照
我怎么知道
你知道吗？
正是因为有雪骄给客人拍照的时间。
我才能够有一些时间。
不去随跟团的行程。
也是
对
雪骄在给客人拍照。
我就抓了个领队
我说
我说一会儿是干嘛？
我说我能不能去坐那个滑翔伞。
然后做完了去找你们。
我刚刚你也说了
就是我们坐载车上去。
江军沙舞
又是另外一份田地。
简直就是北上广的配置。
所有人都在怒天蹦迪。
你知道吗？
特别大的影响声
超级豪华
就是真的是感觉来到了上海。
然后所有人都超级害超级害。
然后那个领队就问我说。
你不蹦迪了吗？
这这么好玩
我说我不蹦了
我去坐滑翔伞
好
那个领队就带我找那个滑翔伞。
反进去
然后就找到那个滑翔伞。
九百八一次
我妈呀？
其实我当时是有被这个价格小小震撼到。
挺贵的
因为我觉得我抱团都花了一万多。
那我还要额外付九百八。
但是坐在就是到了那个滑翔伞之后。
就是我走到那个跟前了之后。
天空就是变成了蓝色。
就是很漂亮
然后室也很开阔
我一问那个
我说九百八
然后我就说那我要飞上去看看。
就我要看
我要感受一下
就是从从顶上面看这一片。
江军山是什么感觉。
我就是
我就是我就是也没有太纠结这个价格。
好
然后
然后就去就是坐滑翔伞了。
坐滑翔伞的时候
我就问我说有没有什么注意事想。
然后那个小哥说他说。
他说跑你就拼命的往前跑。
我觉得这句话就是非常的哲学。
就他适用
他适用于你人生的无数时刻。
就我觉得那个小哥都没。
他可能都没有意识到说。
他肯定意识不到
他无意识的跟我说的这句话。
让我有这么大的感触。
他说你就跑你就拼命的往前跑。
然后我就我就我就坐上那个滑翔伞了。
妈呀我现在就
我现在回想起来都好惊到。
但是说你就跑你就拼命的往前跑。
我就是脑子里就只有这句话。
然后坐上那个滑翔伞的时候。
我小哥坐在我后边。
然后另外两个人就一直跑一直跑。
然后我们就四个人。
一直在那儿一直跑一直跑。
然后跑了大概几十秒吧？
我就到天空了
我超级美超级美
然后你就是在那个天空。
你丝毫感觉不了
就其实温度特别低。
对
然后我就觉得
而且我觉得你
就是如果肯定有一部分看过。
我那个新疆第一天的视频。
也有一部分人没看过。
我觉得如果是看过那个视频的人。
一定能感受到
就我现在为何如此。
还到现在回想起来。
为何还如此激动
我觉得也很难用语言描述出来。
那个时候在天空上。
你就觉得
人生什么烦恼好像都没有了。
那是我真正的爱上新疆的。
第一个瞬间吧？
我觉得
就是一辈子难忘的那种。
然后滑了
然后那个即适的那个光影就忘了。
比起来好一般
光影也很好
我觉得是那个时候。
而且你知道吗？
就飞到飞到那个上枯的时候。
景色很漂亮很漂亮。
就觉得你在这飞一会。
你真的会忘掉很多事情。
然后我就不自觉的就哭了。
就是不是动哭的
就是在那滑着滑着。
就是就是眼睛就湿润了。
然后其实很快
那个过程很快
就大概飞了四五四五分钟。
飞了四五分钟
他就把我放下来
然后那个小哥说
因为980包含360的那个拍摄的。
你就加一下我的微信。
我一会把那个视频发给你。
就是360的那个视频。
因为算是我花钱买的。
他那个视频呢？
滑完我们就去吃饭了。
吃饭我就一路上就惦记着这个视频。
就都是什么时候发给我。
因为当时在场
我只是扫了他
他一直没有通过我的微信好友。
我说我妈的这个
这个瞬间没给我记录下来。
我到时候拿不到我那个360的那个视频。
我这会崩溃的
我去哪找他
我甚至是一度就是饭都吃不下去。
我要回去找那个小哥。
我当时特别后悔
我说我怎么？
我怎么不等他通过了。
我再走啊？
茶不思饭不想再来吃饭。
就是回到的那个
再来吃饭吃这个吃那个。
就是什么也吃不进去。
到快要吃完的时候。
这就已经过去了
得过去三四个小时吧？
我真的以为我被骗了。
我很容易陷入我
是不是我的人
我又被陷入什么骗局了。
这种感觉当中
我说我说好通过了。
我说天呐
我第一句话就天呐。
你知道我等于
他说他在慢慢慢慢一个一个视频的发。
好我就收到了我那个视频。
收到了一个视频
好我开心啊？
我又回味了一遍
我自己发的视频里边。
就是可能只有简短的几十秒。
但是全程我都熬响在了天空中。
大概四五分钟吧？
特别的美妙
前段时间我剪一个视频的时候。
然后需要一段素材。
我就去翻展海庭的视频主页。
然后把钱翻翻翻翻。
因为我前面最开始说了。
我真的很喜欢新疆那几期。
然后就重新我翻到那儿的时候。
我就重新又点开几期看了一下。
然后就看到你做滑翔散的。
那个那一段
就是蓝调
然后天空特别远
然后远处有一条粉色。
然后有大部分是蓝色。
然后你飞在那个中间。
然后这大喊大叫
就是我作为看视频的人。
都会觉得
哇
如果在现场
就是一定会很很感动。
所以我是理解你那个哭的。
真的就是纯粹被眼前的景色所感动。
它没有很
其实它也没有很复杂的情绪。
我觉得还是
大自然真的是会给人能量的。
是的 我同意
我是一个恢复能量的博主。
觉得第一天最美妙的。
让我印象最难忘的就是那一刻。
现在都觉得说
当时毫不犹豫
就是说自己要花九百八。
要做那个滑翔散
真的是太对了
我觉得人生都很难在。
以后可能再花九千八。
都很难有这种时刻了。
会有这样的感觉
然后第一天吃完饭。
我们就回去了
我特别同意你刚刚最后说的那个。
就是花了这个钱去干这个事。
我也是前段时间发的一个。
我自己的自我介绍的视频。
怎么老说我自己
也显得特别那个
咱们就是要交叉聊天好吗？
对
就是没有就是说非要把话题。
往我自己身上演的那个意思。
但是我确实
在介绍自己的一个视频里面。
有说到一个就是我的世界观。
大概是就是说
如果没有金钱或者是。
其他事情的阻碍
想做的事情
就尽量都去做
尊重当下的那个想法是很重要。
但是确实这个前提是。
要有钱
要有时间
对
我其实更想知道
你们晚饭吃什么了。
因为你之前说
在每个餐厅都是他。
茶不思饭
小的一直在那吃
每个餐厅都是他
一爱家爱家试过去的。
我特想知道你在新疆。
都吃了什么好吃的。
没讲饭
哎呦
奇瓦马就是吃了一顿饭。
吃的是吃的是那个蒙古饭。
奇瓦马
蒙古饭
就是奇瓦马吃的
因为其实新疆他除了维吾尔族。
他也有本地的那种蒙古族。
对
所以其实我们奇瓦马之后。
去吃的是那种蒙古餐。
就是点心
但是也很有新疆特色。
就是吃的一些点心。
然后还有他那的咸奶茶。
特别好喝
我超加
其实我发完那个视频。
还有人争论的
就说
这咸奶茶不是内蒙古的。
巴拉巴拉巴拉的
然后就有新疆人站出来。
解释
新疆不只有维吾尔族。
是不是
这个是不是这个
还是很有特色的
就是还有什么酸奶割搭。
然后还有很多很多。
摆了很多点心
各种各样的点心
但是我对那个奶茶。
是印象是最深的
这就是奇瓦马吃的一顿饭。
然后滑完滑香散
回来吃饭
就相当于吃的那种。
原定的是吃手抓饭这些。
但是当年好像是
因为什么原因
就没有手抓饭
就把手抓饭换成饺子。
然后还有那种手切的那种。
羊肉还是牛肉之类的。
然后就是就都挺有特色的。
第一天没有让我觉得说。
我好没有让我在贵州那种感觉。
说实话
就是没有让我觉得。
很难
我跟你说真的很难。
No没有
我真的说
还可以很有特色
对
我跟你说
这贵州美食真的很难。
你超越你当下第一次。
你人生第一口
吃下去的那个感觉。
我现在脑子里面
还储存着
我第一次吃酸汤牛肉的。
你会记得
你会记得在贵州的那个味道。
然后我会一直拿着这个。
我一直又说话
声音特别大
之前在波克里面
经常有人说
那个男生说话
声音太大了
去用扯哪儿去了
说回这个
我会一直记得
酸汤牛肉的那个味道。
然后在今后每一次吃的时候。
我就会把那个味道调出来。
去跟他比较
说
不行
还行
有点意思
大概是这样的
我现在都记得
就我在贵州吃了
酸汤原子火锅
牛军军牛肉火锅
然后那几个味道
但是现在过了这么久。
你真的让我回想起。
我在阿勒泰
这两天吃了两个饭。
我我刚刚都忽略掉了。
因为我真的有点忘记那个味道了。
好就到吃完了
完了反正就是吃完了。
就又扯开了
就是如果我们三
我们四个吧？
再来好一遍
就是如果我们四个就是重新。
再聊一遍贵州的话。
绝对主要的都是在聊。
这是的
是的
真的
所以这就是为什么？
就
不知道大家有没有印象。
就前一段时间好像就是一两个月之前。
网上有一个博主
然后他就是发了一个。
币雷
贵宝
我知道我知道
币雷姐
贵宝那个视频
我靠
相应一段
还有气死
你知道吗？
我我
我当时真的特别生气。
就是我作为一个精神贵州人。
我真的
他们到底在说什么？
就是这种感觉
就是
你自己
真正真正
再去
再去贵州之前
其实我对那个
老子有一个印象
就是
因为我跟他就是
平时深度交流的并不多。
然后我一个大概的印象是。
怎么又在减肥啊？
这种
我现在非常理解
就如果生活在贵阳。
我也这样
减不了肥
就减吧？
反而就减吧？
随便吧？
然后从贵阳回来之后。
如果我们如果
后来如果我们
以后再见面
老子如果说
最近在干嘛？
说最近在减肥
啊理解
应该的应该的
哎
下次还没想好去贵州团建吗？
可以来吧来吧？
可以
等那个还没想好
接到那个商务了
然后我们就去贵州团建。
就去贵州团建
可以可以
茅台赞助一起
好说到阿拉带
真的不能扯远了
阿拉带
然后当天就吃晚餐。
然后就回酒店休息了。
然后酒店休息
这是第二天嘛？
然后就跟雪交
晚上聊聊天
然后就睡觉了
这是第二天
第三天我们就起床。
离开阿拉带这个地方。
我们要去的地方是河墓。
河墓
河墓村是一个
在小虫书上非常火的。
一个景点
然后且且
你们可能有时候会拍到。
且也是一个价格
消费特别贵的地方。
然后河墓村每一个村落。
它都是那种非常漂亮的。
那种小房子
木屋
小木屋
对
有一个很出名的一个点是。
河墓村那有一家肯德基。
然后也是那种木屋形状的。
就很多人到河墓村。
就会打卡可可爱爱的那家肯德基。
对
然后也因为河墓村。
价格实在消费
实在是太贵了
旅游区
很多人就去肯德基消费。
因为只有肯德基的价格是正常的。
那个价格是一样的。
对
是的
第三天就离开了
它就一直开车
一直开车
要开五六个小时的车。
然后才能够到达河墓村。
然后路途会经过阿河公路。
阿河公路我觉得也能撑得上是一个景点。
相当于你车
车在走
你两边的那个雪比车还高。
你进了那个村
你进了
进去是要专门登记的。
因为这些工作人员。
怕你在你边
迷路失踪
或者是整个找不到人。
对
如果是超过多长多长时间。
联系不上你
就会直接就是
默认你
来找你
就这种
你边路特别难
遇害了
对
它把那个雪
就是把你淹没了
或者是
这个很危险的
真的很危险
就包括
因为河墓这个地方。
也可以滑雪
然后我
其实从去年才开始滑雪的。
当然关注滑雪的内容。
好
就比较长时间了吧？
就经常会看到
在很多人在河墓滑野雪。
然后
因为它的那个野雪相当于就是。
你不知道这个雪下面到底是什么？
到底是路还是河
对
很危险
后边就是一个悬崖。
就是经常会有滑滑滑滑。
然后是掉到一个冰空隆。
或者是掉到一个
那个里面去的
就是真的是非常非常危险。
对
然后就是你对就是。
必须要带那个墨镜开车。
因为如果你不带墨镜的话。
它那个
水盲状
会血盲
这就是白毛
但是因为我们没有开车。
我们就是游客嘛？
我还是觉得那个
真的就是有点像走在那个电影里边。
周围那个雪比车还高。
我就一直开一直开一直开。
然后就就这样一直开。
车程很长
五六个小时
我觉得我在新疆能够做到日耕。
也是因为大部分时间都在坐车。
然后我才有时间日耕。
你知道吗？
因为新疆真的太大了。
就是你说五六个小时。
你聊一两个小时的天。
然后你再画半个小时的妆。
你再睡一会儿
你其他时间我就又来剪视频了。
刚刚好
不然我根本无法日耕。
真的我还觉得挺瘦。
我这种博主的
然后其实因为车程很长。
我们就在路上聊天。
所以我们就开始慢慢的就是了解。
让我比较印象深刻的是。
带我的那个领队
然后这个领队叫亨亨。
他在澳洲留学
应该是甚至还读了研究生。
反正是金融行业
回国之后
他就每天穿西装去上班。
然后就觉得金融区的人都是装货。
他就是受不了了
然后他就辞职了
辞职了他就回新疆。
回新疆
然后刚好就
他是新疆人
他就来干福报这个领队的工作了。
我当时听完觉得挺酷的。
就是挺酷的
然后
我很好奇
像亨亨的这种人生选择的。
这种轨迹的变更
会影响到你的思考吗？
就比如说
你现在也在上班
然后会让你有一些。
他可以
是不是我也可以
我觉得亨亨
可能对我的触感
就是那种思考不会很大。
因为我从了解下来。
我觉得很之所以能够这么所谓的。
在我们看来比较任性的做选择。
到家里有钱是吗？
是的
所以我当时就是觉得很酷。
但是我觉得他家里有钱。
可能也不至于说能有多有钱。
但是我觉得至少是一个。
还比较好的家庭
对
但是我觉得
真的是能从一个
我还是很佩服
就是之前能是一个澳洲留学生。
然后现在在这儿干你对。
就是去服务别人
我真的澳洲留学生。
这屋刚刚也说了
也有一个
也辞职了
去海南
卖衣服了
要去海南
给别人做咖啡了
但是这的区别是什么？
是我觉得好与辞职。
他是自己做老板
对吧？
我觉得
好与辞职自己做老板。
然后
你觉得这个差一大吗？
但是我觉得这个领队的工作。
其实我一趟玩下来。
他们真的是
从早到晚都在服务。
我说宽张一点
真的就是到伺候的程度了。
就是
福保对他们管理真的也挺严的。
哼哼给我的感觉
就是觉得我还是觉得他很酷。
就是他敢于这样做选择。
也许他有别的打算。
或者说他在他那个里面。
认为福保旅游团的这个工作。
对他以后
不管是干什么？
是有收益的肯定是。
所以他也是想清楚。
而且我觉得这个里面是。
还有一个是什么？
互联网公司用的词。
收益
是个收益的
装复
我自己也是个装复。
窿户
你觉得自己是谁呀？
哪儿了
啊然后然后这个
有收益有收益
但是给我触动比较大的。
其实是雪骄
就是跟我助一起
借这个摄影师
在福保旅行团做摄影师。
这个工作的雪骄
雪骄
从毕业开始
因为我们聊天途中了解到的。
我就精进地说一下。
雪骄从毕业开始
他非常明确
他说我这辈子都不要做办公室。
这一点对我
怎么会有这种觉悟。
就是我上了七年班。
我才有产生这种想法的。
苗头
对对对
你才有勇气
然后你可能就是
你中间糾扯了一段时间。
你最后真的这样做了。
然后你会觉得说
啊自己就是
就是跨出了人生非常重要的一步。
但是为什么？
有人出生就在罗马呀？
雪骄是不是很年轻啊？
雪骄二十二十五岁二十六岁。
现在流霖哼了
所以你知道吗？
从这一点就非常的触动我。
我就是我会回想我那个时候。
我是根本做不了这个决定。
也这么也不会像他如此坚定的。
所以雪骄到现在
从来没有在办公室做过一天。
他干过那种
他英语还不错
就是他
他英语不是说
他去跟外国人交流很不错。
他很会教学生
怎么考发
怎么怎么怎么考发。
但是自己
扣译
用世教欲王者
对
雪骄就是意识教欲王者。
他凭借着他这一点优势。
从读大学的时候
就开始坚持给人补课。
然后给人提高成绩。
然后真的有好几个学生。
就跟着他那个成绩就提高了。
但是但是雪骄口语一塌糊涂。
然后突然在这个坚持的过程当中。
他就对咖啡比较感兴趣。
然后他就再去新马克上班。
然后因为在新马克上班。
所以自己对咖啡就越来越小又研究。
然后后来他就去大理的那个咖啡店打工。
然后是那种自由职业给自由职业店的老板打工。
然后在这个中间
他又他又拍照比较有天赋。
然后他又接一些拍照的工作。
就是女拍
对女拍约拍
你知道我我非常震撼。
虽然在他非常很自然的讲出来。
我说我好他没有一天让自己饿过。
他他他没饿着
没动着
然后活的萧萧洒洒的。
我天天每个月月底。
一个工资打卡上就开始拿着笔在工位算。
这个社保加这个工资。
然后扣除房租
在这样过
你懂吗？
就我动机特别大
而且还有一个是
后来他就辞了大理做咖啡的工作。
就来福报
呃这儿当摄影师
他来这儿当摄影师是因为。
他没有见到过新疆。
他希望通过这个工作。
把新疆都逛遍开
看遍拍遍
且呃比如说像南疆这种比较微信的地方。
他可能一个人去不了。
他就通过这个工作。
巧妙地拍个够
看个够
一旦他同时也有工资拿。
当然上班都是辛苦的。
他他真的是全程一路上拍的很贵。
所以我觉得这个就是。
他每一步都是那么的。
看似没有规划
他每一步其实都是那么的有规划。
所以就是这个这个小女孩在我面前。
就是就我非常的喜欢她。
就没有缘由
不知道折射出了什么样的情感。
就我非常喜欢雪骄。
对雪骄还有一个对我印象特别深的。
他说了两两给我说两个事情。
雪骄特别爱哭
就他屁大点事
他就是崩溃大哭
雪骄他跟我说
他说他说我就要哭。
他说女生不要觉得哭。
是一件不好意思的事情。
女生要有哭的权利。
感觉老子都被洗了一遍。
然后
人家这爱情也很爱哭。
他就他后来又给我描述了。
好多个场合
就是他情不自禁的。
就是在那儿嚎嚎大哭。
这是一个让我印象特别深的地方。
还有第二个事情是。
雪骄跟我在聊天的过程中。
雪骄让我印象特别深的事情。
是他分享他之前去带团。
然后带团的时候就跟别的领队一起。
然后雪骄就特别想听自己的歌。
就是自己喜欢的歌。
然后雪骄就跟那个司机说。
他说你能不能换成什么什么歌。
哪一首歌
然后那个领队就说。
有本事你来开啊？
然后
雪骄他当时就恨自己。
为什么不会开车
他说
我我年自己就是放自由。
放歌单的权利都没有。
就是他就觉得很委屈。
但是虽然得不出什么结论。
但是那个画面让我觉得雪骄。
特别的有力量
我能得出来结论
就是女生要把方向盘握在自己手里。
这不是一句空话
就是因为我今年过年回家的时候。
就我姐去年还是前天买一辆车。
然后但是他一直开得很小心。
而且就是也是学问。
就是想自己开车
然后就去学驾照
然后买了一辆挺便宜的车吧？
但是就自己开
这过年的时候我就跟我姐聊天。
然后我说那你今年。
就有什么不一样的这种感受。
或者是这种比较特别的事吗？
他又说到这一点
他说我觉得今年就是。
我把车开得更顺了。
是让我特别特别经常能够。
觉得自己真的很好的一个事吧？
我说的可能要乱
我懂你的意思
他就说
说以前如果比如说我想回家。
回家就是说回到爸妈家。
就是如果之前我想回家的话。
那我可能得让你姐夫开车。
或者是你还等他的时间。
你还得就是看
有时候可能打摄影号的。
看他的心情
或者是要不然我就得自己打车。
打车又很贵
然后要不然我就可能自己骑电动车。
我们家跟他们家的那个距离。
其实没有很远也没有很近。
但是就是骑电动车本身是一件。
就相对来说比较辛苦的事吧？
如果路程比较长的话。
所以他得出来的结论就是。
我今年把车开得特别顺。
我特别特别高兴
我想去哪就去哪
我不用看任何人脸色。
我不用等任何一般公交车。
我手里边握着自己的方向盘。
一脚有味我就走了。
你知道吗？
就是我觉得我之所以跟。
学交的那个聊天当中就是。
没有一个完美的结局。
是因为学交现在还没有。
握到那个方向盘
但是他说了
他说了一句话说
他说女生一定要有。
要去争许
给自己放歌单的权利。
这是我跟学
这个也很妙
就是一个年纪比你小好几岁。
然后你在跟他的聊天的过程当中。
你发现他有比你更早的。
醒悟明白一些道理。
我当时我会
我也觉得很喜欢他。
而且这些道理
我觉得我算是到30岁。
这个节点才会慢慢慢慢的。
去想的事情
对
然后我觉得在这个里边。
因为学交跟我的这些聊天。
让我印象很深
然后在这个阿河公路。
领队开车的
这个五六个小时的途中。
我就突然拍了一下。
领队的肩膀
我说
我说我想听什么什么歌。
我说我要放
然后
当然我知道这个背景。
是因为我花了钱的。
我是顾客
我不是学交那个层面的那种。
但是
脑梁就是花钱的
我就是买了一个服务。
我就要听这个歌
然后在那个公路上。
就放了一首那个王妃的歌。
就王妃在春晚上唱的那个。
那个叫什么来着
世界赠于我的
啊世界赠于我的
我妈最近在跳这舞呢？
然后特别大的白雪。
然后在公路上一直走着。
然后那个车子里面想起了。
王妃的那个世界赠于我的。
那个赠于你各种
赠于你疾病
赠于你鲜花
赠于你什么？
哇你突然觉得
嗯爽啊？
我要单曲循环
这种
又回到说
刚刚我们一开头说聊天。
说介绍一下行程
行程也就那样
但是我觉得这个路上的人。
和景色
以及你偶然发生一些事情。
他真的让你
让你真的是深度思考。
你是在郭卫斯考不出来的。
嗯
这才是旅行的意义。
对真的
这很很很俗说的
但是确实真的是
就是我也是
包括我为什么最后就是把。
还没想好这个主题定成。
我们的每一次出发。
我就是觉得其实出发。
是一个特别好的事。
就是你出发就会有新的发声。
然后认识一些新的人。
然后就会有新的感悟。
就是你的
但是如果你一直
只在一个地方的话。
就是生活
它是很重复的
你很难就是掀起什么连遗。
我最近
我好像前几天
就是在备忘录里面。
我还写了这个事
我觉得就是
对于我们三个主播。
都30左右的这个年纪。
就是我觉得对于我们。
这个年纪的人来说。
你会突然有那种
表达的欲望和
新的想法的蹦出
是一件非常非常奢侈。
和宝贵的事情
是的
我甚至我自己作为一个。
算是一个表达者吧？
就是或者是一个
这种内容创作者来说。
我一直在输出内容。
但是我其实
很多时候是在
找我之前的一些思考。
或者是我
我从别人的思考里面。
就是可能加工了一些。
我自己的感悟
这些
但是我真的从
去年的吉林到今年。
我
又去海南了一次
然后又去贵州出差。
然后我现在又来
西藏拍这些内容
就是你的每一次这种出发。
真的
会让你
更新一遍你
身体里面
和大脑里面的东西。
我真的有这种感觉。
对
然后还有就是可以。
就是其实可以从我。
个人的那个账号里面看出。
我只要一出去玩
数据就很好
就是其实
并不是因为我出去玩。
花了更多的精力
或是有更多的
更多的设计什么之类的。
其实出去玩
相对的剪视频的时间。
是压缩的会更紧的。
但是我觉得是因为。
其实背后的原因
还是因为出去玩
我就是会有更多的思考。
它就是非常自然的流露。
比如说
新疆的那些
就很多评论里面都说我。
比如说文碧很好
我觉得不存在这件事情。
就是是因为这些人。
比如说包括雪骄
包括领队
他们给我的
给我带来的
它就是这么发生的。
然后你就是这么转述的。
然后还有就是在那个。
就是比如说我们去万里玩。
然后后来我就给雷拉。
写了一封信
然后那封信
然后草莓姐就评论说。
她看枯了
但是那封信就是
我两三分钟就写出来了。
就是是我非常自然的表达。
就是没有任何设计。
或者是花言巧语
所以我觉得就是
女型
真的女型的意义就在于此。
就虽然她比较实的表达。
然后我们那天在那个。
阿河公路路程比较长。
得有五六个小时
中途我们就在一个景点。
就是也是景点下来了。
就一起玩
白雪矮矮
全部是白色
然后中间有一棵孤独的树。
然后你人就站在那个树的。
一个边边角角
你就这样看着树
然后然后雪交就插一张。
哇神篇神图就这么出来了。
你不需要有任何造型。
你也不需要穿那种漂亮衣服。
就是自然是你的衣服的那种感觉。
就是随便拍就在那拍照。
拍的很好
就是拍的很多很好看。
然后在那
我就在那
你对就突然就把我抬起来。
然后往雪地里面扔。
然后我就滚进雪地里面了。
特别深
然后把我扔了两次。
然后就大家就玩得很开心。
然后无人机也飞起来了。
就让你在那走
大自然特别大
你就在那走
无人机就在顶上飞。
然后后来拍出来的那个无人机的。
那个视频也非常的好看。
然后因为一些素材的倒入。
我没有剪辑视频
这一段
然后反正就是无人机的视角。
也非常非常的好看。
然后在这玩的时候。
我就突然想起了
我去年去墨河的时候。
去年去墨河不是因为很不开心吗？
又是一个人
在墨河玩的就是比较沮丧的那种。
但是也是尽力让自己在开心的那种。
但是我就觉得我今年玩的好开心。
怎么这么开心
这种感觉
我发现就是我并不是。
家里边的房贷还清了。
然后家里边没有欠款了。
让我压力小了
而是我自己变好了而已。
就你看那事情的角度变了。
然后你所属的世界和。
就是你接受到的这些人就变了。
对
是的
就是我不感谢
比如说我妈又
苦难
对
真的我一点都不感谢那些。
我只是因为我现在变好了而已。
就是前几年
我自己每年都会给我妈。
在过年的时候转两万或者三万块钱。
我今年就一分没有给。
我觉得这个改变也是。
在我整个人生逆程当中。
是非常重要的一个改变。
因为再往前倒几年的时候。
我每年拿出两万三万对于我。
来说是一个非常
要使蛮劲才能拿出这两三万块钱的。
那种感受
所以每年都给的我非常的吃力。
然后今年一分没给。
这是一个
然后还有一个是
我今年从收入上
也比往年好了很多很多。
就一切都是因为我自己在变好。
所以我觉得现在防黄带对于我来说。
也不是一件有压力的事情。
所以我不感谢那个防黄带。
我也不感谢任何困。
我不感谢我的家庭给我任何经历。
就我就在那个学弟里滚。
我觉得太好了
然后就非常感谢
感谢我自己
然后就想起来去年默和。
在那玩的一趟就玩得很开心。
然后我们从那玩了之后走的时候。
我们在路边看见一条非常肥美的狐狸。
肥美
就是肥美的狐狸长得特别漂亮。
然后尾巴也特别的漂亮。
一般在路边看到的狐狸。
它都是被人类味的有点。
有点营养不良了
就是你很难在路边看到。
一般那种肥美的狐狸。
都是躲在那种深山里边的。
你真的是非常难得的。
在路边就见到那种很漂亮的狐狸。
然后我们走的时候居然就看见了。
然后也特别的神奇。
然后就开开开开开。
开到了荷木村
然后入住了荷木村的民宿。
然后接着就是去吃那种小木屋吗？
是小木屋
全部都是木屋
格衣很不好
群里边还吵架呢？
我好真是十几个人出来玩。
真不是件容易的事情。
然后好像就说到晚上了。
就是因为两个人玩的太嗨了。
然后就一直在那吵吵吵。
就吵的就是另外两个人。
是一对情侣还是什么？
就睡觉睡得不好
然后在群里边
就是你一言我意欲的。
No不重要
我完全忘了同行的团。
还有其他人
我不在乎
然后就住住的民宿。
我就去吃晚饭
这顿晚饭我印象特别深。
就是吃那个图火锅。
锅长得跟老北京的。
那个铜锅
涮肉的锅是长得一样的。
但是它端上来是给你调好。
味道的汤
那个汤特别味道
里边全是牛肉
哇
这特别大一坨一坨的。
那个牛肉煮的特别难。
我现在特别饿
我当时不是还在
刚做完手术不久
还在芭恒恢复
然后芭恒恢复
期间是要自己牛羊肉。
就要少吃牛羊肉的。
我在那狂吃
就是完全忘了
自然闹那个锅里边的。
真的超级好吃
图火锅一定要吃
口水都飞我嘴上
这是我印象
这是我新疆印象最深的一顿饭。
那个图火锅
然后吃完晚饭
我们就去
那个荷木村那去逛。
因为刚刚说了
荷木村它确实是一个旅游。
其实非常发达
成熟的一个地方
然后我们就去那儿。
有一个勾火网会
我是非常不喜欢
蹦迪以及酒吧这种氛围的。
我都很讨厌
我不知道为啥
我就是不爱去
然后到了那个勾火网会。
哇
超级嗨
真的就是野外少数民族。
那个时候少数民族的那种。
天生的那种
带动氛围的那种能力。
和情绪会感染到你。
你会觉得他跟北京的酒吧？
完全是两回事
然后就在那儿拿着话筒。
就在那儿
啊啪啪啪啪啪啪啪。
然后唱着各种的歌。
有流行歌
有各种就是
咪咪咪
你要跳舞吗？
就是那种
你情不自禁的就跟着唱。
超级多人
然后有的人就把自己的狗递上去。
然后在那儿
让那个工作人员
在那儿拉着一起蹦。
然后有把自己的大江相机。
蹦上去
然后在那儿
大家一起嗨
人为肉人
起码二三十圈
然后还有警察在那儿。
寻多
超级多
真的很
还是很容易发生踩踏的。
那个现场氛围超级好。
然后中间有一个巨型的那个勾火。
然后大家就在那儿。
台上就是工作人员。
四五个工作人员
拿着话筒
然后在那儿嗨
他们都穿着那个民族服饰。
然后下面就是站着。
一圈一圈的人
然后唱的都是那种。
特别有氛围的歌
然后又特别冷
但是大家都好像是忘记了温度。
然后就一直那儿嗨嗨了好几首歌。
没有任何拉踩的意思。
但是就是
哈尔滨的那个冰水拉实际。
也不是也有一个蹦滴吗？
我和老子十年前前天还是什么时候去的。
是那个兔子舞是吧？
是不是要在那儿跳兔子舞。
对
差不多吧？
就反正不好说
对我我我我能记住的感受就是太冷了。
啊没有任何
但我这个是完全不记得那天很冷。
那个时候有一个明显的感受说。
就是觉得整活这方面真的还得少数民族来。
对
这种感觉真的
他们好有天赋啊？
这种感觉对这个对那个勾火印象也特别深。
啊然后晚上就
玩完就回那个
呃民宿住了
这第三天就结束了。
我想问一下
河目的厕所是像网船的一样。
就是都是那种汉厕那种特别脏的那种地方吗？
哦
说起厕所就是经过阿河公路那五六个小时。
跌的实在是不行
然后就是要上厕所。
就在中途给我们找了个厕所。
巨脏
就可能那是那个中间唯一的一个厕所。
巨脏我就说
我不行我受不了
我上不了一点
好同行车里边的其他人。
就去上野侧去了
就在雪厅上野侧
我我我我我那个时候。
心里的那个防线还是完全突破不了。
我就去我就跟着他们。
我说我当时不知道野侧是什么意思。
他们说要去上野侧野侧。
我就以为是另外一个厕所。
我说问我去上不上野侧。
我说我去我去我去。
我跟你们一起去
结果去那了说
说雅婷到你了
你进去吧？
我在这给你看着
我说我说
那我还是忍忍吧？
然后我就上车了
你看这两天
你就是城市人
我就是个装祸
就是上野侧这种事对我来说。
就是今儿一切
天呐
好吧？
我当时就是憋上车。
我跑遍了一天憋死我了。
幸好你问这个了
这是那个行程中很重要的一环。
不是那河墨的厕所呢？
你们做的民宿的厕所呢？
还好我们那个民宿特别好。
还有专门的
还有专门的那个洗衣机和烘干机。
然后我就趁那一天。
就把前面三天的脏衣服全部洗了。
还挺好的
对
然后晚上蹦完低我们就回去了。
然后就晚上跟雪娇又。
聊天
又聊聊过
雪娇聊得大哭
哎呦
雪娇聊哭了
你说啥了
但是我觉得这个就涉及到雪娇工作。
你边的相处的
她会觉得就是很难受。
对
所以就是有一些委屈的哭了。
但是哭完之后呢？
还得在那就是网盘。
拍照
对
还得把那个当天
当天所有游客的照片。
上传到网盘
雪娇给我拍的那个照片。
我觉得是有
是有我视频情绪的轰托。
以及人和人产生故事。
有交集
以及风景很美
大家会觉得雪娇给我拍的照片。
特别的好看
然后以及我跟雪娇。
有一些感情的递增。
会显得我在新疆拍的照片。
非常的好看
但其实我去新疆
也没有带多少漂亮衣服。
但是那个照片拍出来。
就很有感情
也很好看
然后我把这个旅游团带的。
小小的火了之后呢？
就有一些人对雪娇拍照的。
期待值纳的特别高。
然后我觉得
这也是我跟雪娇带来的。
一些没必要的
她
她这样都拍累了
她拍不出来了
她
然后这一趴打过
然后第三天就结束了。
第四天的行程
就是在河目的那个。
极客普宁滑雪场
是亚洲最大的滑雪场。
这一天的行程
就是在这滑雪
就是一上午
我就去滑雪
滑完了之后吃个饭。
下午又继续去滑雪拍照。
行程就是这个
但是那一天
我突然早上起来就要加班。
所以我就没有去滑雪。
然后还有那一天
我情绪特别低落式。
早上群里边大概是八点多。
然后就人爱图
我说带是去试了
我当时
我当时是不相信的。
那个时候还没有确认。
真的去试
都不相信
对
我当时真的是
我真的是一点都不相信。
然后当时
我当时还发了个微博。
我说拜托拜托
一定要是假的
那个时候应该是上午八九点。
然后因为我就是觉得。
那是假的
所以我就带着电脑出去了。
因为我觉得我还可以正常滑雪。
然后拿着那个滑雪服。
到了雪场之后
就跟我说是真的
我当时我当时就是很震惊。
我就觉得还是假的。
然后因为
我觉得你们肯定也比较喜欢大小S。
对
而且我觉得
也是算是陪伴我们。
就是那种非常生动的一个人。
就从小
然后我小时候
我小时候也看了很多大S。
就是演的电视剧
大S和小S我都非常喜欢。
我印象比较深的两件事情是。
小时候那个时候还是那种光碟。
就我妈特别爱看偶像剧。
然后看各种偶像剧。
就去外边租碟子
在我们那个隔楼那边看。
就放那个碟子看
它租的是那个流行花园的那个碟子。
F4和大S演的
让我早早的就睡觉。
那个隔楼只有一个电视和一张床。
我就假装睡着了
然后我就把那个枕头盖在我的头上。
然后悄悄地露出一个缝。
然后偷看那个流行花园。
超级好看
贼帅
怎么会那么帅
然后那个时候我爸还在开那个修女铺。
给人修博托车
然后我晚上就做梦梦见那个F4来我家了。
就四个人超级帅
就硬要来我家看我。
然后因为那个修女铺又特别的脏。
我家又特别的小
就没有房子
那个时候我们一家人就住那个隔楼。
然后那个
我说怎么办
那个没坐的地方
然后那个我跟我妈就拿出那个修女铺。
里边的小榜凳
就让F4就坐在我们家修女铺的门口。
特别羡慕大S
觉得他
觉得他怎么？
他怎么能能能这么生动。
就是
然后当时
嗯
我什么时候能变成大S。
然后还有就是
到大学的时候
就是我一个朋友叫陈紫剑。
他开了一家摄影工作室。
他特别喜欢看那个康熙来。
我就跟他
就是经常重复的去看康熙来的片段。
我至今记得那个沈玉琳。
讲那个跟他宝牧的那个偷看宝牧洗澡。
讲他朋友偷看宝牧洗澡的事。
你们是不是也刷到过。
我真的都快要轮背了。
然后沈玉琳
我有
我有印象
但是我报了
反正就是反正就是很抓。
然后沈玉琳跟他一个朋友。
就是上那个康熙来了。
你看脑子肯定知道。
然后那个沈玉琳就是很抓。
他张口就来的
然后他就说
他就说那个他的好朋友就是。
家里边有宝牧
然后他的那个好朋友。
喜欢偷看宝牧洗澡。
反正就是这么一个梗。
然后那个沈玉琳
讲他跟他朋友
他跟他这个朋友的感情的时候。
特别搞笑
说好像是
好像是他生病了
然后他朋友就来看他。
然后给他准备了一碗汤。
还是什么之类的
然后
沈玉琳就看着那碗汤。
然后那个就说
就说
哎呀？
今天怎么那个房屋在滴水呀？
怎么房屋在滴水呀？
哦
一看是我的眼泪
哈哈哈哈
放别人生
我就觉得
怎么会有一群台湾的艺人。
能够
这么生动
就这么会聊天
就这种感觉
所以就特别选他
我现在讲的时候
我都没觉得大爷是去世了。
你们知道吗？
就是
我不觉得他他去世了。
对对对
然后我也是我也是。
然后就一边加班
就没有去滑雪
然后一边加班就
就其实就是
就没有崩溃大哭
就是一直就就这样扶着。
然后就
就一直在磨眼泪
当天
确定去世了之后
然后微博上很多人都在。
因为我玩微博很早关注了那批人。
他们几乎都在聊大哑。
对
吃饭
这就到吃饭了
我也很难过
就一直在这吃
我起码吃了四五万米饭吧？
就是有点有点情绪心机。
进食了
啊？
后来就去
就反正就跟着去打卡了。
那个咖啡店
然后一直到那天晚上。
那天天和
那天和木天气特别好。
雪交说
他们前几个
他们前几天
前几个带的团来和木的时候。
都碰上天气不好
但和木那天天气特别好。
然后我们6点半就一直到下午6点半。
我们就爬上和木的那个。
呃
一个小山坡
然后去等那个南调时刻。
因为南调时刻拍照特别好看。
就整个天空都是蓝色的。
对
然后完了之后呢？
我没什么拍照的性质。
反正就是我整天
一整天都很低落
完了之后我就一直在那坐着。
我没有我没有拍照。
雪交又在挨个给人拍照。
我就一直坐闹
一直看
你知道你知道现在在网上。
比如说有人会去专门打卡什么日照金山。
就比如说什么四川成都会拔山射水。
就打卡那一座山
就在那等日照金山。
你知道在和木每一座山都是日照金山。
就你走在村里边那个。
那个这个山头也是日照金山。
那个山头也是日照金山。
超级美
完了之后一直就等太阳落山。
然后慢慢慢慢变成橘色。
又变成红色
然后到最后变成所有的天空都是蓝色。
整个晚上都是蓝色的。
我就坐着
然后最后就躺躺下了。
然后清新就出来了。
这个景色会对你的这个心情。
有好的影响吗？
就是我看到星星出来的时候。
我会觉得
我会觉得大S是不是变成星星了。
就是就我会想我会想说。
大S如果你是在这么美的地方。
变成了这颗星星
那我觉得也
你应该
你应该在那个世界也很幸福吧？
就是就是会会这样。
就是还其实还是心里有点接受不了说。
大S去试了
对
然后就一直发呆
然后我那天就结束了。
嗯
然后我那天晚上的晚餐是去一个居酒屋吃的宵夜。
吃的烧鸟
我也没什么性质
我就一直觉得特别冷。
然后这一天就结束了。
嗯
我觉得是属于
是属于就是情绪非常低落的一天吧？
又加上一直在加班。
哼
说的特别沮丧这一段感觉。
对
然后我现在我现在。
偶尔就是还是会看一些大S的片段。
然后看到一半的时候。
就我刚开始刷到的时候。
我不会觉得大S去试了。
但是突然看到他跟小S。
比如说在节目里边互动的时候。
我看到一半
我才突然反映过来。
哦
就是原来大S这个人不在了。
就是就是
现在会是这样
对
我最近也是经常能刷到大S的就是片段。
每一次都觉得好可惜。
特别可惜
嗯
对
我几乎都是
我现在就是刷到一半。
我才反映过来
嗯
反正第四天就这样过去了吧？
哦
对
在这我还要讲一下。
那个和牧村那个南调时刻。
就那个南调时刻
你上去了之后的景色是。
下边是一个小村落。
每个村落都是这种三角形的那种房子。
然后上面铺满了白雪。
然后到晚上的时候。
天空是蓝色的
然后这个每一个小房子都亮起了橘色的灯。
就是其实特别好看。
就是就是一片
下边是一片橘色
特别的温馨
然后上面是蓝色的。
然后很多人都会提着那种一个。
小的纸露灯
然后在那拍照
然后硬的特别好看。
对露营灯
然后在那出片
在那特别好看
和牧村是
消费特别高
这是事实
但是我觉得那个景色。
还是挺值得打卡的。
然后第四天就结束了。
第五天就离开了和牧村。
第五天早上起来的时候。
我又小小的哭了一下。
第五天的行程是离开和牧村去美丽风。
美丽风这个地方
和牧村到美丽风
距离不是很远
就是稍微坐一下车就可以了。
然后我们就在这
这个稍微坐一下是多少。
第20分钟
我们就到了美丽风。
美丽风就是去体验骑马。
然后坐那个爬地
爬地就是一个马拉着你。
对就上去体验了一下。
然后你知道吗？
我上去上到了那个美丽风。
我还在那打开电脑。
还在那干干干干干。
关注那个
因为那个苹果电脑特别的冰。
加上温度特别的低。
那个手套特别大
你又敲不了
你只能把手套取下。
你在那你在那敲
我敲到最后
我那个手指已经冻得邦硬了。
然后就把电脑合起来了。
就在那个美丽风拍照。
然后航拍
巴拉巴拉的就体验结束了。
就到了中午吃饭的时间。
中午吃饭
我印象比较深的是一个叮叮炒店。
我不知道你吃过
叮叮炒面
知道知道知道
我首先我觉得
我在大学就印象很深。
我觉得叮叮炒面
这个菜名取得特别可爱。
对
对对对
是的是的是的
叮叮炒面
我特别喜欢吃叮叮炒面。
其他的菜印象不是很深。
但是味道都非常的可口。
然后
但我觉得还有
还有想说的是
这些饭菜已经是在根团里边。
质量非常高的了
就是你能吃饱
你也能觉得很下饭。
而且都是新疆菜
但是新疆不是应该美食很多吗？
这是我印象中
我感觉你都没有吃到。
就特别特别有特色。
就是比较特把印象的那种新疆菜。
对
涂火锅
至今都没
至今都
哎
第五天了
至今还没吃上大盘鸡。
其实心里有在变
大盘鸡
手抓饭都还没吃上。
对
好
然后咱们就是爬立。
美丽峰就玩完了
回来就吃饭
那个叮叮炒面我印象特别深。
然后我们中午吃完饭。
我们就继续坐车
就正式离开了河牧村。
然后在这个车上
我就从第五天
就是行程跨结束了。
我才跟我们同车的一对夫妻比较熟起来。
这对夫妻他们是之前。
就玩衣礼体验
特别好
也是跟着福保的团。
然后冬天又来玩
这对夫妻就是家里边有80年的。
做鱼肉火烧的
鱼肉火烧里边
那个鱼肉供应的这个经验。
然后呢？
我觉得对于我人头上。
对于我这种上班族来说。
就是很有钱了
真的很有钱了
就是那个姐
咱们叫姐
静姐
全身上下的名牌
然后那个哥就是带着那个表。
就是十几万吧？
好像是
然后我觉得有钱人。
就是因为他们之前玩过衣。
他们也很喜欢雪礁。
然后熟了之后也比较喜欢我。
然后我觉得有钱人表达喜欢你的方式。
就是恨不得给你塞钱。
就一路上都在请客。
就其实我们那个餐饰已经很好吃。
每顿都吃得非常饱了。
路过哪
就是看见那个景区有卖烤肠的。
就给你买烤肠
然后看见这个景区有买水的。
就给你买水
就是什么都给你买。
就是完全就是没有A这种概念。
脑子里没有AA这种概念。
说还要给你转钱
No
然后
就我们就在车上就聊天聊着聊着。
然后就说
啊那那个我说
我后边到那个宝
可以去宝殿玩
因为北京你宝殿很近。
很近很近
对
我倒是压根没想起来那个豪雨。
是那个河北人
河北
豪雨就是宝殿人
对
我压根没想起来
然后我就直接问说。
那那个哥
下次我去那个宝殿。
你是不是那个
到时候派那个车队。
家里边的车队和保镖来接我。
好
然后就在这埋下一个伏笔。
就说那以后
ok
下
对
以后我们会聊一次。
一起宝殿
可以
然后后来也真去了。
就他们是
也会也会邀请豪雨。
才
然后我觉得给我一个。
给我一个感受是什么？
就是其实反而有时候。
那这种真的就是
脚踏实地创业的有钱人。
他其实更低调
就是更温和
就他没有就是那种。
特别装的说
炫呀什么之的
你这完全感受不到。
我今天还跟豪雨就是。
有说一个
今天的感受
就是我们
今天不是在西藏会合了吗？
六个人
因为我们是分别三不二人。
然后到了拉萨这个地方来集合。
今天就是雷拉霸和那个。
有一个老师叫吴老师。
他们来的
我跟吴老师只见过一次。
豪雨这是第一次见吴老师。
然后在整个饭桌上。
就是吴老师给你的那种感受就。
非常好
这个好的点就
让你描述不出来
都不是那种说
像静姐和他们就是说。
给你买烤肠
给你买这个
没有
这是一种日物戏无声。
然后我就跟豪雨说。
我说也是吃的一个火锅。
但是那个火锅真的。
吃的是一个毛牛肉火锅。
但是真的不行
一会儿我跟你说
咱们在云南吃的那个真的。
真的顶到了我跟你说。
就是西藏这个毛牛肉。
或者就是我们没有选对店。
这是不好吃
又有标准了
真的不好吃
OK
说回到吴老师
能一起播客
能发展20个主题。
说下期聊
这个下期再聊
回头但不跟咱聊
你要
好
那个火锅
辽毛牛肉火锅
对
然后我跟豪雨在打那个火锅料的时候。
我就说
真的感觉这种真正厉害的人。
都是向下兼容的设计。
是的
就是那种感觉
就是他其实
你对于他来说
你就是一个
我怎么着都行
但是人家就是有那个。
哎
那那那种能力
让你感觉到
哎
让你觉得很舒服很温和。
但是其实人家就只是在。
正常
调到了你的这个频率上。
对
是的
然后完了之后
因为这个靳姐跟凯哥这一对夫妻。
然后他们不是刚刚说的。
他们玩过一礼团吗？
跟雪娇比较熟悉
雪娇在路上说
嗯
就是喜欢吃蛋塔
然后靳姐跟凯哥走的时候。
给雪娇买了
说是买了四五十个蛋塔吧？
啊？
就是他们要一起吃。
就是给他们一起吃。
就是就是他们会非常细节的。
记得
比如说雪娇爱吃蛋塔。
然后完了之后
第一天
就请雪娇他们去洗脚。
去去唱歌
去
但是他们这些
就是表达得很自然。
你能感受到是出于对你的认可。
跟喜欢
他才会这样对你
而不是他在炫耀什么？
就我觉得反而有时候真的就是。
比如说这种
踏踏实实自己做企业。
真正的有钱人
他是真的很
他不是偶像剧
或者是段子里边的。
那一种形象
你懂吗？
这个还是给我有一些反差的。
嗯
但我觉得也分人吧？
应该
对也有可能
有没有可能只是他们更会演。
啊？
你这人好好好好
好阴暗呀？
阴暗的老鼠
哈哈哈
思想太那个了
如果他们演的话
我也不太可能第二次去保定。
我不太可能
而且我觉得如果就是演。
能演到这种程度
那
那也是个高人
也是个高人
对这可以演没没问题。
嗯对我们这一趟
第五天在路上
就跟他们比较熟悉。
然后大家聊天聊的啊？
比较愉快
然后我们接着就到了三湾。
这个景点啊？
三湾就是可以理解。
我是一个非常巨大的。
河流一个湾道
然后完了之后
两边都是树木
如果夏天的话
就像这个季节
三湾可能就会更好看。
南天白云绿草花
然后中间一条河流。
但是我们去的时候。
相当于河被冰住了。
然后所有的都是白雪矮矮的那种。
对
嗯
但是就在那打卡了一下。
拍简单的拍了一下照。
但是在这让我印象比较深的是。
这个三湾的景点
它有那种树起来的音箱。
就它可能也是为了有客体验。
然后树起来的有三四个音箱。
然后像电线杆一样。
每一个电线杆的头。
头上就挂着那个音箱。
等我们拍照结束
然后这个突然
就想起了南莲花这首歌。
就你知道
在非常空旷的那个大自然。
还有山 山间
然后就可以
那种
哇
我当时觉得
哇 好美妙呀？
我说
能在这放音箱的人。
真的是个高人
我不会
你当时真的会被
那首南莲花打动
就你从来没有在这种场景。
之前称词就听听耳机那边的南莲花吧？
然后又是又是又是那个。
读书时候的那种歌。
就会觉得格外触动。
然后就一直开车一直开车。
就晚上就到了民宿。
哎呀我怎么写的
第五天吃的土火锅。
随便
哎呦别说了
别说了
好入住入住
然后去到入住民宿。
真是没什么记忆这美食。
真的好吃吗？
我现在打一个问话。
我但是没有说
新疆美食不好吃的意思。
我以后会去
亲身的去吃一下
好
然后呢？
晚上就入住了民宿。
接着呢？
我们怕就是会比较呃。
就是怕第二
就想想买一点
那个晚上吃的凝嘴。
啊？
我们就去了一个小卖部。
全市竞节凯格请客哈。
嗯
反正就是我也是一分钱没花。
好
第五天结束
下次带我去保定
可以吗？
可以
好
第五天结束
第六天
第六天有一个重大的好消息。
就是一起床就纳死了。
因为我
我前面几天在新疆。
没有看到任何蔬菜的影子。
你知道吗？
蔬菜
我是一个蔬菜狂热爱好者。
贵州的蔬菜不要吃。
西藏这也没有蔬菜。
贵州所有的蔬菜都免费。
哇靠
我真的是终于纳死了。
不许说
是不合不合不合不合。
不合野菜
对
然后第六天起来的时候。
就是
就咱们就是一个进行的一个。
大拉舌拉
大动作
然后非常的舒畅
这个心情都跟着舒畅了。
然后在这里我建议。
以后到这种
比如说西藏还有新疆。
这种就是不方便
没有有蔬菜比较少的城市。
大家可以提前买一些。
助消化的药品
就谢药都行
就是就是那种
这好之适合植入广告。
好似吧？
这太是植入广告了吧？
一定要带点通便的。
健卫消食片
西梅汁
然后如果你消化实在是不好。
你就干脆带点谢药。
就这种
你真的就是有时候。
你不好吧不好吧？
你旅行途上
不拉屎真的体验感。
身体不是很美味
然后第六天就是
就是这个
然后完了之后呢？
我们就是开车去了神仙湾。
哇靠
真的是神仙住的地方。
就是一去神仙湾
全部起了那个雾气。
那个雾气就像
西游记里边
孙悟空大捞天庭的那种雾气。
超级超级美
这个雾气就在
就围绕你整个人
同时那天太阳超级大。
然后就是相当于
阳光一层一层的穿透了这个雾。
就超级美
你继续往你走
就是那种河流
河流没有被动住
那个河流还在往下流。
因为温度太低了
可以想象
就像碎碎冰一样的。
一点一点的
就是往下再飘
就那种那种感觉
哇超级美
超级美
在这拍了好多好看的照片。
然后神仙湾
大家一定要去打卡一下。
就是如果哪个
冬天阿勒泰的女城那边。
女行团那边
没有神仙湾这个地方。
我建议不要去
就别参加
对我建议就别参加。
我建议就是被骗了直接。
然后神仙湾就是打卡。
就是我真的是超级好看。
然后我就在那
就是因为雪娇要给别人拍照。
然后雪娇给别人拍照的。
那个过程呢？
我就一直站在那个河边发呆。
雪娇给别人拍
雪娇给别人拍照
这七个字像是一个分号。
像是这个
这七波克里面的分号。
然后雪娇就在给别人。
在给别人拍照的时候。
我就站在那
然后就站在那个河边。
我就找了一个最近的地方。
然后那个雾气就围着。
我就看着那个河流。
在我面前流动
然后那个河上面飘着那种。
像那种冰沙一样
一片一片的
碎在了我的面前
眼前
然后就继续又往下流走了。
哇超级超级超级好看。
超级好看
然后天空又特别烂。
然后你就在一个围绕的雾气里边。
真的叫神仙湾
名不虚传神仙湾
然后我后来发完视频之后。
我发现很多人都说。
他们在神仙湾
拍到了自己的朋友圈背景。
人生照片
对人生照片
拍到自己朋友圈背景。
好几个人都这样说。
所以神仙湾还是一个。
特别值得的地方
真的是神仙美景
然后接着我们就去吃饭了。
吃了什么？
我有点忘了
就去吃饭
吃饭想起来了
是在一个村落里边吃饭。
然后那对饭吃到了大盘鸡。
然后也吃到了拌面。
然后那对饭特别好吃。
特别下饭
但我觉得女油团是不是抱团玩。
如果饮食能够用下饭来形容。
其实就已经是非常高的评价了。
是的
统一统一
吃饭的地方叫白哈巴村。
然后我们住的地方也叫白哈巴村。
然后继续走
然后就找了一个空框。
白哈巴村是哈巴雪山下面吗？
不知道
就到继续把我们带到一个空框的地方玩。
领队就拿出了一些轮胎。
一些玩具
然后又给我们堆了很高的山坡。
让我们在那滑雪
在这我印象比较深。
因为这个时候跟雪交的感情。
已经得到了一些生活。
然后轮到雪交给我拍照的时候。
雪交就说
他说我想到了一个非常非常好的拍照的点子。
然后他说
他就给我找了一片非常干净的雪。
就没有人踩过
他就说你就去踩这个雪。
你就踩到中间
然后意味着你走了一条没有人走过的路。
然后
你有没有觉得雪交这个人特别妙。
有可能这些话都是他无意识说出来的。
但都很哲学
然后我就踩
真的那白茫茫的一片只有我踩出的那条路。
然后他说停就在这停。
停了之后他就
他就说你张开双手。
你背对着我
然后我面前就是也是雪山。
特别美的雪山
然后最下边有一个村落。
然后有一些森林里边的树。
然后你把手张开
然后我就张开他又给我拍照。
我记得这张照片
然后后来他又说
你躺下你就躺在这。
所以我就觉得
当时就是特别妙
我印象就是特别深。
然后接着拍完照
我们就开始玩
然后领队就开始推你。
然后就在雪地里边滑呀？
什么之类的
反正玩得很开心
然后也拍照拍的也很开心。
然后我们晚上又回到了白哈巴村吃饭。
在这就是晚上就吃的拌面。
也是在吃图火锅的同一家餐厅。
我就说我就不想在那等了。
我就想出去走走在那个村里边。
妈呀幸好出去走了。
不走这后悔一辈子。
这个时候天空就是粉色的。
就是大面积的粉色。
特别粉特别粉的时候特别好看。
但是这个时间就是没有。
没有延续的特别长。
吧那个最浓的那个粉色的时候。
我就一直在那个粉色天空下面发呆。
我觉得旅行
是一个人
对我就一个人
因为他们都在屋子里边等饭。
我有时候觉得旅行的美妙之处。
就是你的临时决定。
比如说我临时决定去花香伞。
我临时决定要出去走走。
就一直在那发呆发了二三十分钟。
然后看那个粉色的天空。
非常大面积浓照着你。
就感觉就是你
就你被大自然拥抱的那种感觉。
就是感觉就是
老天爷觉得
张雅婷这个人很棒。
所以这片粉色的天空就送给我了。
那天晚上
送给你了
我就收到了
我心愿接受
我谢谢老天爷
我感谢我自己
谢谢老天爷
接着就晚上吃完饭。
就回到了百哈
就是百哈八寸的那个民宿。
然后晚上又跟又跟学校聊天。
学校给我说很多有意思的事情。
然后学校给我展示了他的笔记本。
然后有一篇日记本给我展示了他的日记本。
他日记本里边写他25岁很迷茫。
他觉得他不够漂亮。
然后不会打扮
他说他一世无成
我说
然后我就问他
我说学校你现在还这样想吗？
学校说
我不这样想了
因为我现在清晰了。
你知道我只是在那个时候觉得很迷茫。
我说那你现在清晰了有多清晰。
他说我现在很清晰。
我就想拿着我的相机去全世界旅居。
他说他说他要用他的相机记录。
记录下来
我说你非常确信吗？
他说是
我问了他三遍
他说当然呀？
我非常确信
我觉得我的旅居更加坚定。
也是因为这天晚上。
学校给我看他的笔记本。
学校非常
我反复问他三遍
他非常坚定的回答我。
也给我
我觉得现在我这样语言描述。
可能会有一些矫情。
但是我觉得在那个晚上。
学校给我看他的日记本。
以及他非常坚定的说。
他想要记录这个世界。
全世界的旅居
就是很
很让我感动
然后我当时也觉得。
如果有机会的话
我想跟学校旅居一两个城市。
对
虽然就是没有
一辈子就跟学校捆紧。
没有这种感觉
还是想有机会的话。
真的很想跟学校旅居一两个城市。
对
这种
然后
而且就是到后边
学校翻正翻正他的笔记本。
他突然说
他说我给你唱首歌吧？
然后他就拿着笔记本。
然后在那唱了一首英文歌。
一切都很美妙
然后唱的也不好
然后他唱得很不好意思。
然后他唱完了之后。
他说我到底在干嘛？
我为什么要给你唱歌呀？
为什么要突然给你唱歌。
然后就结束了
这一晚上
好妙啊？
是不是
怎么怎么样
我喜欢这一天
我回来跟陈姐和冯姐说。
我说
我突然就是来了一句说。
我要跟学校去那个女居。
我觉得她们也挺崩的。
就她们可能也
心里也有个问号说。
这玩一趟有必要吗？
感情就是激增到这种程度吗？
你让你这么坚定吗？
然后张眼庭当时跟我说说。
她学校以后要去青麦。
想去青麦女居
然后到到时候
她也去
然后我的回答是
那我也一块儿去
好
学校如果听到这的话。
到时候那个就是
咱们家个人
家人啥转
第六天就结束了
然后第七天就是
我想comments一下第六天。
我喜欢第六天
很美好
对
朗子说的那个特别。
就是特别妙
而且就是很
很难设计
对
对吧？
点是在于
突然拉实了
学校突然有一个想法。
要给你拍这个
好看的照片
晚上吃饭的时候
你不想等
你突然出去走
就看到了粉色的晚霞。
晚上回到民宿
只要突然又给你唱歌。
对
就是非常随机
然后又很
美妙的一天
我喜欢第六天
但是你刚刚不这样说。
你就是我不知道这一天。
都如此之妙
我会
我之前会觉得妙在。
妙在晚上那个
她实在是设计不出来。
包括唱歌
包括看日记本
包括就是我觉得
能给另外
能给简单的
相处五六天的人
突然看自己的日记本。
我觉得也是一个
真的就是打开了说。
那我们聊的比较多了。
我愿意给你看我的日记本。
还有我觉得
日记本那边写的
那种迷茫
非常非常的真实
还有一个比较搞笑的点是。
学家写到说
他觉得生活一成不变吧？
那个成语怎么说的。
反正学家写了个错别字。
写成了一层不变
他写的一层楼的层。
他写的一层不变
要是一层不变
他写成了一层
楼层的层
特别可爱
然后他当时都没发现。
他写错了
然后我在那看的时候。
我说
怎么是一层不变
然后他赶紧说
他说
我怎么写的一层
这种
然后当时还有
还有他里边还写了。
他在新巴克上班
然后学的咖啡艺
咖啡技术
日记本上写的
咖啡棒要转到三点钟的方向。
非常的生动
我觉得
雪礁可能至今不太清楚。
他所带给我的启发。
会有如此的内容
他可能只是觉得
我们是一个非常交心的朋友。
但是在这里
我还是非常感谢雪礁。
他的坚定
以及不经意间的透露的真诚。
以及一些想法
都其实在我后来的生活当中。
都让我很有启发
也包括他确实更加坚定了。
我要
以后我也要去全世界的决心。
第七天就是回阿勒泰市区了。
就一直开城开城回去了。
两点的时候
中途经过了一个不耳惊世吃饭。
下午4点40的时候就到了市区。
那个时候勒扎的票房是二十亿了。
那一天
你们俩至今是不是还没看过勒扎。
看过看了看了
没有
那你那个退出国籍吧？
我只能说
入美国国籍
我
少给我胡说
我爱国爱大爱人民。
我们在拉萨
然后去吃饭
那个餐厅
它是在一个商场里边。
商场上去
我发现
他写的几个字是拉萨电影院。
然后我就特别好奇。
我心想拉萨电影院会不会有那个。
就是
不一样的片子
藏语的那种片子
或者是怎么怎么样。
这个背景是
我之前在抖音上班的时候。
就是我做过很长一段时间电影。
包括票物什么的
然后这些如果有机会的话。
再跟大家分享
然后我就很好奇
我就抱着这个好奇。
就往上走
上去之后
一副巨大的哪吒
我说
到了哪儿
都得看哪吒
但是你知道吗？
那个时候
哪吒是十亿还是二十亿票房。
因为我本身
我还是很认可哪吒一的。
所以我觉得不错
我想看哪吒二
但是我觉得是说
哪吒票房发展到一百亿。
破百亿或者一百四十亿。
我觉得很多事情
都发生了机型的变化。
这个我们后边
也可以再聚集
再聊一下
我觉得也挺有意思的。
对
就是包括这种电影。
然后像哪吒
我觉得包括
之前其实好东西出的时候。
我就特别想约你俩的人。
包括浩语什么的聊一期。
但是当时就是没有想清楚。
你知道吗？
就是这个主线
然后包括一些其他的东西。
我觉得
以后有机会都想跟大家聊。
然后我们到了阿达市区。
我就一心想看哪吒。
我就说
都网上都这么火了。
我一定要今天一定要把哪吒看了。
就阿达还不是很小吗？
就找了一个电影院。
那个画质特别差
就把哪吒二给看了。
对
然后那个时候看还是还是觉得。
挺燃挺不错的
但是我觉得哪吒发展。
后边很多尼普的事。
刚刚说了
咱们后边再聊
哪吒看完了之后呢？
就去就跟雪娇去吃饭。
因为我想看哪吒
就错过了那个
所有团的人一起
结束的时候一起吃。
那个大餐的那个
吃火锅的那个
因为我觉得
因为
是其实是太好了
我真想说这个
就是那个
然后他们就喝了很多酒。
然后
然后也玩得很
玩得很嗨
我跟
我跟雪娇是一起去看了哪吒。
对
然后完了之后
哪吒看完了之后
我们就去
雪娇在这特别可爱。
然后她说
她一直说哪吒
哪吒哪吒什么之类的。
她说
到底念哪吒还是哪吒呀？
什么之类的
她就她就搞不清楚。
她就两个就对焦剃者在念。
在读
好
然后我就跟
为什么？
她是重庆人
重庆人重庆人是分不清楚。
重庆的方言
好像就说的
哪吒哪吒什么？
哪吒
对对对对对对
所以她就有点装潢不过来。
我跟她把哪吒看完了。
我就跟雪娇吃饭
就去找了个纳面店。
一起吃饭
晚上那个
这又回到了这个保定夫妇。
就说要
硬是要请我们
又要请点
不请点
一天不请点就难受。
说一天不给你资点钱。
有情人他就难受
所以我晚上说
找一定要和我们去玩。
说那个在酒吧？
那个男模都给我们点好了。
什么之类的
那我觉得
那当然她只是开玩笑。
那我觉得就是有雪娇。
我就无所谓
然后我们晚上就去到酒吧？
去到酒吧？
然后大家就
就随便嗨了一下
我确实不喜欢酒吧的氛围。
但是我靠酒吧？
你看到几个女生长得嘴漂亮。
就是新疆人
怎么可以这么漂亮。
就那个鼻子
我的妈呀？
我觉得那个鼻子是。
是唐大花这辈子都。
梦想的鼻子
真的
怎么会有人伸出来这种。
真的这么挺达
又
唐大花会听到这期节目。
可以
无辜的被Q了两次。
就是在酒吧？
你看到几个长得特别漂亮的美女。
然后觉得赏心悦目。
每一会儿就从酒吧走了。
又跟雪娇闲聊了一会儿。
但是就没有发生很妙的事情。
但是也整体还是非常云越的。
然后这七天的阿勒泰行程。
就结束了
但是我的新疆之旅。
其实并没有结束
因为我后边又请了七天的廉价。
然后因为福宝在最开始邀请我。
我让阿勒泰之后就去伊犁玩。
因为阿勒泰体验比较好。
所以就坚定了说可以去伊犁。
是的
对吧？
我觉得这个也挺妙的。
而且我觉得你当时就是。
又继续请假去伊犁。
我觉得
我觉得做得很正确。
对
我觉得伊犁让我认识了福宝这个人。
就其实前七天福宝都没在的。
福宝只是线上
对
让我就是
我觉得我们可以
伊犁行程可以再单独再调。
对
但是我觉得
我觉得也可以再稍微提一下福宝。
福宝前面也说了
就是他做一个女生。
他这我觉得他这个是一个大女主。
他自己就是战胜了癌症。
然后且我觉得还有一个很妙的点是。
还没有打算去新疆之前。
我在视频里边说
希望我下一次去新疆福宝健健康康。
我去伊犁
刚好是福宝
在杭州治疗结束
第一次回到新疆
时间卡的正好
因为有很多粉丝也因为。
抱福宝的女友团想看到福宝。
也有好几个博主
有的是大博主
有的是小博主
都没有见到福宝
因为福宝在杭州治疗。
而我的去伊犁的时间点。
福宝抗癌结束
然后回到了伊犁
然后福宝后来不是。
你们应该也有在网上看到。
也经历了很多网报。
什么创业不容
我觉得也
那我的阿勒泰就到此为止了。
好 我有个题外话。
就是想说一下
也不是题外话了
是不是女生和女生。
在有交集的时候
更容易产生这种
不管是星星相细也好。
是这种比较深入的情感。
我觉得我特别羡慕这一点。
就是我可能在日常生活中。
或者我出去玩
很难有这种感觉
就是和一个人能够交流。
交得这么深入
你知道为什么吗？
我其实想过这个问题。
就是因为我们很少一个人出去玩。
就是如果你是两个人出去玩的话。
就比如说这次去新疆。
是我和张阳廷两个人一块去的话。
他肯定不会跟雪娇有这么深入的沟通。
有这么多故事的发生。
就是可能他新疆的这几期视频。
就变成了一个特别搞笑的那种。
或者是一个那种气质的内容。
就是我跟朗子出去玩的次数特别多。
我们一起出去玩
你也不会去单独去。
比如说跟别人打话。
别人也不会很声音的说。
能跟你们俩一块说的话吗？
但是一个人就很容易发生这一切。
我觉得可能是这个。
我觉得这是前提
然后还有一个是
我觉得运气也是一部分。
真的
不是每个人说都能遇到雪娇也好。
福报也好
如果比如说我当时因为大厂。
这个因素
我选了小巴郎
那我觉得也有可能会因为。
这个原因跟他的团。
然后如果一开始我没有发视频。
露出福报能吃那个包装盒。
那也不会产生福报的闺蜜说。
让福报来看看
就跟一块一块一块一块一块。
我觉得运气和命运的成分。
也在这个里面起了很重要的作用。
当然
比如说我去普尔那一趟。
其实聊得比较好的。
有普尔景麦山的姐姐。
以及普尔菜包鱼的老板。
但我产生更深的联系的。
其实是后来的普尔菜包鱼的老板。
对 我觉得人和人就是一段一段的。
那我们阿勒泰要不今天就聊到这。
然后期待咱们的
希望大家努力催更我们的一离形成。
这样我们就更动力更新啊？
那我们就今天就这样。
好的 今天就这样。
希望你开心
拜拜